[Music]
[Applause]
night
thank you everybody for being here I'm
your host Tim P of timcast IRL thanks
for coming and let's bring out our
panel there we go we got Ian
Crossland next
up I'm talking
about the
suspense Sheamus coglin of Freedom
Tunes
love you here we go we got luuk rowski
of we are
[Music]
[Applause]
change Luke and here he is Charlie Kirk
from turning point
USA and honoring us here at T USA once
more it is an honor and a
privilege Tucker Carlson is back to join
[Music]
us o Charlie Kirk thanks for having us
back on stage thanks man it's amazing to
have you absolutely it's it's wonderful
it's amazing to see so many people and
uh we'll just we'll get into it with
everybody here this is uh it's a big
year- end show for us we've we got
Donald Trump's approval rating his uh
his polls against Joe Biden are are
through the roof in swing states he has
a tremendous Advantage with voters who
did not vote in 2020 Joe Biden is in the
gutter and so we are looking at
political Victory right now we're
looking at cultural victories with the
likes of Public Square building the
parallel economy with Angel Studios and
their movies and of course with a
massive crowd and what we're seeing here
at Turning Point USA so the big question
is with all of this success and all this
hope right in front of us what can we
expect next year and what do we do to
keep the momentum up and avoid losing it
I think we're going to the best thing to
expect is equal response you're going to
get an equal and opposite response so
we've got to think clear and we've got
to be have slippery minds and willing to
do new things that have never been done
before awesome new technologies things
that people won't be expecting and
Implement them fast like uber was
implemented yeah I think one thing
conservatives have to be very careful
about here is not assuming that we're
going to have a victory because everyone
was talking about the Red Wave day in
and day out without us actually
coalescing around a central mess message
and because the only thing we had to say
was we're going to win rather than
putting forward a strategy for doing so
we ended up getting clobbered and I'm
worried that we have the potential to
see that happen again in
2024 I I I don't know if I would uh uh I
know a lot of people felt like it was a
clobbering with the midterm but I think
while we do see tremendous cultural
victories I'll give a shout out to uh to
Benny Johnson he had that amazing clip
that I saw on on X where he was shouting
out this massive audience and showing
the lack thereof for some other
personalities while I think we certainly
are doing really well culturally and
winning the hearts and minds of people I
think what a lot of people missed in
20120 and 22 was winning elections is
not just about convincing people to vote
it's who counts the votes and that's my
concern now going into 2024 we can we
can sit here talk about polls all day
and night are we going to have the the
procedure behind us to actually win
that's I mean you're talking about
electronic voting man you need to know
what that software code is because if
it's trick and behind the scene and
I maybe I can say that in this audience
uh you know what word I'm talking about
Charlie kick them out we need to uh we
need to be prepared I I think that
demanding open source or free software
voting like code like a gpl3 so at least
we can look at the code it doesn't mean
that people can't hack into it and that
that might still be an issue but at
least we know that the machines are
doing what they're supposed to do if
we're going to use those yeah I mean no
serious country no country serious about
democracy would ever use an electronic
voting machine and many don't um because
anything digital could be manipulated
look at Wikipedia look at the internet
we're entire por of History are now gone
um so I would I mean I would just demand
that we have no electronic voting
machines why would you even want to
worry about that but I would say um that
you don't want to give the other side
credit for being straightforward or
honorable cuz they're not and so it's
not a question of convincing anyone the
argument against Trump in 2020 wasn't a
wall is bad you can't make that argument
the argument was you know he's a bad
person and then we had covid which of
course was the kind of pivotal fact of
that that election so I I think you have
to assume if we have another pandemic
pandemic or a war particularly a war
between now and election day that is
either you know an intentional act to
subvert our democracy or it certainly
will be harnessed for that use so I just
wouldn't assume that it's going to come
at you straight and head on you know
what I mean yeah we have to understand
people don't relinquish power peacefully
The Establishment has a lot of power
that abusing right now we're dealing
with criminals we're dealing with
individuals that have committed scops
that have committed horrible atrocities
on the people of the world that have
started Wars that have started literal
gene splicing chemical biological
warfare against the people so we have to
understand there's going to be something
that's going to be happening here that
we should be absolutely paying attention
to as we're dealing with u essentially a
multi-trillion dollar propaganda machine
but it is being wrecked by posters
and memes it is being destroyed by
individuals speaking truth to it it is
being destroyed by individuals coming
together coalescing and saying enough is
enough of this bull crap I am done my
life has value I am standing up for
myself I am standing up for this country
and that is a danger to The
Establishment that they fear and in that
fear we're dealing with a cornered
animal that cornered animal is dangerous
and they could act out in many different
ways and I they're capable of anything
they're capable of something that we
can't even imagine Luke's just cranking
it right up to 11 right get started so I
can but in terms of what Tucker was just
mentioning about war I'm hearing a lot
of talk about a potential full scale war
with Russia at something that could
potentially subvert Us in 2024 well War
Means War Powers for the people waging
the war so these are people who think
only in terms of power acquiring it
preventing you from having it so they
see it I mean you see war in terms of
its human cost or maybe it's
geopolitical effect they see war in
terms of their own fortunes and their
own power so the second out war and
there's a long history of this in the
west when war broke out in 1940 in in
England the government later run by
Winston Churchill our hero put the
opposition party in prison with their
families where they stayed without
charges and that's been you know that's
been epsteined it's gone uh as a fact
but it's that actually happened so don't
underestimate the ability of a
government at War to use its new powers
to crush criminally Crush its opponents
there's a there's a journalist by the
names of uh name of Steve Baker who is a
contributor to the blaze who has tweeted
that he he was in instructed to turn
himself in tomorrow for charges related
to January 6 this guy you see a picture
of him he's wearing a suit he's got
glasses he looks like your your
quintessential journalist Richie
mcginness who's a friend of ours and
also a journalist who worked for the
caller said this this guy's
unambiguously a journalist and he told
them only a few months ago they'll never
arrest you for this but now they're
doing it so how about no I mean when is
the first person going to stand up and
say this is fake this is political I'm
not submitting I mean I don't know it's
at some point they're going to force
people to do that everyone in this room
believes in the system grew up in the
system was proud of the system for its
unique fairness globally unique no
system was fairer than ours and that's
the main thing that we were proud of As
Americans and no longer is and it's
transparently political particularly
January 6 stuff there's like it's been 3
years this is insane and so someone at
some Point's going to be like I don't
know you're going to have to Ruby Ridge
me because I'm not playing along that's
worrisome it is worse but I'm saying
like why does everyone why does everyone
pretend like this ghost system which is
merely sort of a you know a a a gross
grotesque imitation of its former self
still is real it's not real you're
speaking my language everybody knows
what two words I want to say but I'll
throw it to Charlie instead no I mean
look the Empire is going to strike back
in 24 what that looks like we don't know
and in in 20 they did declare war that's
what Co was Co was a domestic
declaration of war that gave unelected
bureaucrats unlimited power to change
the voting laws and they're going to try
to do it in 2024 probably a foreign war
but who knows and we have to be prepared
for that if we want even a chance to win
and people ask all the time do you think
we're going to win I I have no idea well
these rules are all still in place yeah
I mean mostly universal mail and voting
we've we've minorly changed some things
in Georgia Wisconsin some things Arizona
has gotten worse actually we've gotten
less secure in our elections here and
also let's not kid oursel there there's
probably going to be a scop there's Pro
probably going to be a false flag we're
living through one there's probably
going to be an agitation and and our
reaction to the next thing whatever that
next thing is is going to be critically
important
and this is why I think there's such a
massive effort to take down Twitter to
take down Rumble to take away people's
ability to call out the scops in real
time which are happening right now and I
think the system is kind of scrambling
because I think they had a lot of things
down the pipeline but they know they
can't get away with it it's a very
dangerous Gambit that they're playing
right now and I I don't see things going
well the longer this goes on and the
more that we don't know what the future
is going to be in in front of us with as
they're desperate that's what waiting
around is not the solution because if we
just petition them to hey please stop
electronic voting we can't see the code
please give us the code it's not going
to happen we need to build systems that
are better or in parallel like we could
vote legitimately on the the machine or
wherever with paper and then on a
blockchain voluntarily like volun it
would just take a lot of us to do it and
then we could check and see if they're
accurate and that would be one way to
move forward it it is tough I mean uh I
I agree with what you're saying I agree
with what Tucker was saying yeah let's
not have electronic voting machines open
source the code do whatever you got to
do
but there's a practical question of what
can we do right now with less than a
year in front of us the the best thing
is use x and Twitter because it's
obviously a threat to them they wouldn't
want to shut it down or go after to Elon
if it wasn't working the greatest hope
we have in 2024 is we have a sliver of
the Public Square back that we didn't
have in 20 and that's why they're going
to try to either indict Elon or they're
just going to try to crash Twitter
through a DD attack or some sort of
foreign threat they're going to try to
take Twitter down by the summer the EU
is going after him now they just announc
obviously no people are saying things on
Twitter that you're not allowed to say
and they're going very viral very
quickly and public opinion is changing
too rapidly can I can I just point out I
think it was Dave Smith who pointed this
out to us on the show that before Elon
Musk purchased X if you said men are not
women you would be banned that that
actually happened I mean it is it is
quite remarkable to be fair the gains
we've gotten back I mean it's a
tremendous loss for the fact that we
could not say I'm one of the biggest
social media Platforms in the world
aren't women they actually banned Megan
Murphy for saying that just that it's
very innocuous I find Twitter is a is a
vulnerability at this moment the way
it's built the centralized system so if
we can decentralize that thing into a
protocol and still use it and it's fast
enough there's still issues with like
Noster where sending video is uh is slow
but it doesn't mean it's always going to
be slow we can use mesh networks so that
if we all have Twitter on our phone and
four of our phones go down the other two
are going to keep the network going I I
I do think that you know what Turning
Point USA is doing right here is one of
the most important things bringing
people together people are meeting each
other all throughout this building and
even in the streets even at restaurants
yes that culture building is the most
important thing because as we all know
it's been in quoted 50 billion times
Andrew breart politics is Downstream
from culture someone told me this is
like the RNC now this is basically why
not just this is the RNC de facto MH I I
I I can't take that as a compliment
if you might have meant it as an insult
what you call it the RNC Tucker it's
like NATO it sucks huge amounts of cash
and demands attention and does nothing
useful
time to abolish it and it subverts
Poland in it um no I uh yeah comparing
anything to the Republican National
Committee or convention is just it's an
ugly slur it's an ugly SL I'll take it
as what the RNC should doing exactly you
know having been around this stuff my
whole life and spent my whole life life
in Washington the true Corruption of the
Republican party I don't know it just
took I was like 10 years behind on that
speaking my language that but but now
that I now that I see it I'm like I
can't even believe this exists Because
by the way in some ways it's more
offensive than Democratic party because
it's lying the Democratic part is just
like we're here to hurt you and and
belittle you of course but the
Republican Party pretends to be on your
side they're like quizzing but they're
they're literally they the the
Republican Congress just allowed the
Biden Administration to spy on
Republican
voters so like is there a bigger sign of
the fact that they hate you every bit as
much as the Democrats what I love about
this though is I I agree with you
however if you are on the how would I
describe this the lower end of the IQ
bell curve you don't understand what it
is Democrats are saying they're doing so
for instance when they say they're going
to have uh free trade it's good for
everybody when they say we're going to
increase environmental regulations and
increase taxes to the average person
they're like this is good it makes the
rich pay their fair share but to anybody
who knows anything they they they
they're they're like hey wait a minute
this is going to drive all of our
manufacturing base overseas where they
can ship their products back for dirt
pay people and China dirt and have no
environmental regulations so this is why
Trump takes actions when he did in his
first term that resulted in a lot of
manufacturing coming back but see we can
understand that and I'm not trying to be
too much of a dick but there's a lot of
people who don't understand the basics
and I'm sorry but sometimes I do argue
with them on X and they say you know I I
remember this one conversation where a
guy said you know food comes from the
store and I said yes but where does that
food come from he go what do you mean it
comes from the store and I said my God
help me I'll help you I was there for
that convers
like like what do you mean milk's coming
from the store and I'm like there's a
supply chain I think you got to build
trust and it's challenging was someone
you disagree with but if they trust you
they're more willing to change their
mind about the things you're saying and
you mentioned Tucker about learning
about the corruption of the the
Republican party and I kind of watched
it in real time on TV and 2006 78 uh
when we were the Iraq War was kind of
lit up and I remember you were into it
it seemed like you were on the side of
the Republican like George Bush and the
movement and then what John Stewart came
on one day and you guys just had it out
and it was like humiliation and he's
like please stop arming America but the
way you were looking at him was like
really listening to him was that was
that a moment no I I thought and I still
think that he's a mediocrity and um and
I think time has proven me right on that
absolutely but what's interesting is
that by that point I mean this is not
even interesting at all actually but my
views on Iraq which I had I had a daily
TV show leading up to that war and I had
kind of endorsed it sort of
half-heartedly against my better
instincts but I did I did I did that I
felt ashamed about it ever since and
then I went to Iraq in December of 2003
20 years ago this month and I got
through the day they captured Saddam and
to greet and I watched the whole place
fall apart and I won't bore you with the
details but I realized that everything
I'd advocated for was a complete lie
that this was a disaster that could only
hurt my country which is the only
country I really care about and by the
way it eliminated the entire Christian
population of Iraq which I guess we're
not allowed to say but if you're a
Christian you should care what happens
to Christians globally and I must say
they do bear the brunt of almost all of
our foreign policy and no one says that
it's happening now happened in Syria and
it's like shut up you're not allowed to
notice that why I'm a Christian and I
care about other Christians why wouldn't
I and they do wind up bearing the
disproportionate harm in our foreign
policy adventures and you have to ask
yourself why is that honestly what I
don't know the answer but it's super
evil well I I kind of I I feel like a
large component and I think you were
saying this earlier if not the component
of what uh uh the culture war is is the
destruction of Christianity of course
well yeah it exactly it's a destruction
of Christianity there's also a
destruction of Innocence uh Americans
unfortunately will look at our foreign
policy as if it's something entirely
removed from our cultural realities and
attitudes but the truth is we have
promoted a callous disregard for human
life over the course of decades because
abortion was legal Nationwide across
this country prior to the overturning of
row and if you think sending women the
message and Men the message that they
can wage war against their own unborn
children does not have effects on the
global stage and that a person who
doesn't have to care about the life of
their unborn child is supposed to care
about children in Gaza or Yemen you're
out of your mind but unironically a lot
of these neocons um they're usually
pro-life even though they want to start
World War III and they want to send your
kids to fight a foreign war but that's
why they're pro-life they need more
babies to go send a war ex well yes I I
think that that's also component to but
there's also a lot of hypocrisy because
a lot of the chaos that was created by
this foreign policy was deliberate Dick
Cheney in 1991 was specifically talking
about why we can't get rid of Saddam
Hussein because if we do it's going to
create chaos inside of the Middle East
it's going to kill the Christians it's
going to kill all the different SE
sectarian Muslims there that are going
to be fighting each other it's going to
make Iran more powerful in the region
it's going to create a vacuum and they
did it they knowingly did it after 9911
the Republicans after 9911 were on the
wrong side of history and they set up
the institutions and the apparatuses
that are now going after their other
fellow Republicans and putting them in
jail
and and that's a hypocrisy that needs to
be called out and those people in that
party need to be purged there needs to
be there need to be consequences for the
actions that they've taken they have
literally done everything they could
have possibly done with the role that
they had to destroy our country and
ensure that the people do not have a
prosperous future and what happens I
mean we put all of the decision-making
in the hands of people who pay no price
when they're wrong I want to I want to
throw back to what you were saying
Tucker about uh you know you being on
the wrong side of that and you you know
regretting it all that stuff I think
everybody everybody here now agrees and
that's is why they tremendously respect
you it's because you you say things that
are true you learn things and then you
correct yourself you you you evolve your
opinions and here you are you know many
of us we we've watched you for so long
and you take a look at the other
conservatives in the establishment with
the rise of Donald Trump and what did
they do all of a sudden now they're
indistinguishable from Democrats they
they're the antithesis they are the
people who said I don't care what's true
or correct I care about what grants me
political power and now we're looking at
Old neoconservatives who have
effectively joined the Democratic part
party or super packs that are going
after Trump and and my favorite thing is
when Trump in 2020 in 2020 after they
announced Biden wins you have groups
like The Lincoln project saying oh our
fight's not over it was never about
Trump well it's just a Democrat super
pack with old old Republicans now saying
whatever Democrats want to hear to make
money yeah but I do think it yeah I
agree with every word and I work for
some of the people that you're referring
to and it's horrifying to me to see them
change but I do think a lot of it has to
do with what's going on inside them and
they won't admit when they're wrong and
that's a tragedy for the country but
it's also a tragedy for them there is
nothing better for you there's nothing
more liberating there's nothing more joy
inspiring than being able to admit when
you're wrong it frees you from the
burden of the mistake that you made
that's totally real you don't have to be
a religious person to believe it it's
the basic precept of AA it's the basic
precept of all true Liberation movements
begin with you admitting that you're
probably not a super great person and
you don't have unlimited power it starts
with you being honest about yourself and
if you can't do that you are in a prison
and that's why they're also fearful
every word is measured they're afraid of
saying the wrong things why because
they're afraid of being exposed if you
tell the truth you have no such fear
You're Not Afraid at all cuz you're out
there you don't even care and if you
hurt someone's feelings if you say
something stupid which you will
definitely do you just apologize for it
and it's better it's like I don't
understand it's like not a hard concept
and no one in DC can do it yeah humility
it's a it's a blessing to be able to be
hum it's the greatest blessing I love
there's also there's also a big
distinction here that I think is is is
very uh important to kind of call out
here because when we have these two
sides we have the establishment and we
have the anti-establishment the bigger
distinction is one side is is a bunch of
bloodthirsty neoconservatives that want
war and death and murder the other side
want want of course none of that they
want uh peace they they are anti-war
principally anti-war and for for years
now there has always been an attack no
matter who you are if you are anti-war
and I think this is a key issue that's
going to be very important for this
election cycle cuz I do think something
in Ukraine something in Europe is going
to be that galvanizing new Pearl Harbor
like event and I think we need to speak
up more be more anti-war more than ever
uh because this is the key Crux issue
and for years Bill O'Reilly uh
previously called me a Jihad loving
liberal when I was criticizing the war
Chris Matthews when I was criticizing
the war a couple years later called me a
right-wing racist teab
so you got a great resume I didn't
change on my on my philosophy I didn't
change on my point of view I have always
been anti-war I have always been
anti-establishment the system has always
been proar and that's the big
distinction here you're you're living
through a realignment that's promising
and Tucker you helped lead it you're
sitting in a room that watch this we
should not send one more dollar to
Ukraine to that gogo dancer named
zalinski we never should have sent him a
single dollar the issue is should ask
for the money back hold on you're
sitting in a conservative event that is
applauding for something this has all
been realigned it's all changed that an
event like this that would have been
predominantly conservative would have 20
years ago been totally on team
neoliberal and every thinker would maybe
they might been a little bit contrarians
here and Tucker what do you make of that
that all of a sudden the home of not
just America first but skepticism about
these Foreign Wars and Adventures now
lives in the conservative movement well
I think it of course it's mostly Trump
who did that and I was just the pivotal
moment in the last election in the 2016
election that changed my view of
everything was the night of the debate
in Greenville South Carolina when Trump
said you know that we didn't get
anything out of the Iraq War it was a
mistake and I remember all the Dumbo on
television I mean covering politics is
the easiest thing you could ever cover
right and so these are really these are
mouth Breezers these are low IQ people
and they immediately like check the
notes oh South Carolina is the highest
military population per capita of any
state and so they all look at oh he said
that in South Carolina he criticized the
Iraq War he's going to get creamed in
the primary and I thought the people I
know having been in Iraq and know lot of
people who serve there the people who
are madest about the Iraq War the people
whose lives were disrupted or ended or
severely injured by that war and of
course he won and it was at that moment
he won the South car Department it was
at that moment that they decided Bill
Crystal and and the rest of the ghouls
who were s of thinking about how to
subvert this campaign and like draw its
energy for their own dark ends they
decided oh well we have to stop him you
know and that's when the realignment
happened on the left where Liz Cheney
and Bill Crystal and all these people
whose core problem is they could never
admit that the Great Adventure of their
life the Iraq War was wrong they could
never admit it and if they just admitted
it I mean Liz Cheney has lived with this
burden and she's obviously a
bloodthirsty freak but one of the
reasons that she is a bloodthirsty freak
is that she's never been able to be
honest about her own complicity in this
crime and if she would she would be
totally free of all that and she like a
normal human being who her husband could
love again and it would just be all good
but she can't and and they're all like
that you know what I mean she was raised
by one well there's that the family the
family business is invading other
foreign countries and displacing
millions of people lying about it and
then but who would go into that business
like who would want that I think only a
severely damaged person like the problem
is inside them that's I just think
that's true they're trying they're
trying to acrew resources and it's
either that they're trying to get the
the oil out of the Middle East or the
poppies out of the Middle East they want
fuel so this is why I push a lot of
hydrogen in like Redevelopment of our
hydrogen industry at home so that we
don't need to go steal resources
elsewhere the problem then is trade
routes they want a trade route into the
into India through the Mediterranean and
they want to secure this that's a tough
one to not Ian you're being too logical
here yeah also but but I can I just yeah
so I just want to make a point here
about the conservative anti-war movement
and why I'm so optimistic about it I'm a
firm believer that an effective anti-war
movement has to be conservative because
when you look at the things people fight
for the things that motivate people to
enlist it's God country and family and
when the left is anti-war the way they
discuss it is God country and family are
stupid and you were an idiot for
fighting for those things and what
conservatives can say is those things
are valuable those things are good you
are a brave and good person who was
manipulated by Liars who don't care
about those things and we're using you
to profit well I I I do think you're
half right Sheamus what I often hear
from better than usual better than usual
from when the left talks about anti-war
there there are people I know I've had
conversations with and I'll make sure I
carve out respect for them but typically
it's this country or this war is an
affront to to family and faith and and
and and stability in the economy for the
other country America sucks we hate
America America should be funding these
yeah a lot of this is not for profit a
lot of this is not for strategic
American goals I don't think these
people care about America these people
literally go to the Bohemian Grove and
do mock child sacrifices they literally
do Spirit cooking where they take bodily
fluids and try to summon demons they
literally go to private islands where
they hurt little babies and children in
unspeakable ways that we can't even
mention here on this particular freaking
broadcast these are evil Sinister human
beings that I truly do believe are are
are worshiping a larger outside entity a
satanic evil entity it sounds reductive
to say that but if you look at
everything they do it doesn't add up
until you put in the kind of spiritual
aspect to this they have been hijacked
they are not real Souls they are
individuals serving the greater
evil real quick want to ask a very very
quick question of everybody okay uh
Sheamus have you ever been arrested oh
man why you got to ask me that here yes
you haven't okay uh Tucker have you ever
been arrested I've been taken into
custody twice Charlie no no okay uh have
you ever been detained no ever stopped
and questioned uh in Israel yeah okay uh
that means and and we and Ian you you've
only ever been detained yeah my buddy
had weed in the car that means for
everyone here on the stage you have
served oh I we know you've been arrested
seven times for journalism okay this
means got to arrest it on the way here
that everyone here has has has done more
time in any context than anyone on the
Epstein Client List for the Epstein
Client List it's like the liberal
economic order man it's the least worst
world order shout out to Owen Shroyer
for making that point but but this is
the issue that brings people together
and I want to kind of change this
conversation a little bit because if you
look at Left Right Center everyone
agrees hey uh what they were doing for
for decades with the FBI covering up
child abuse when Witnesses and and
people came to them and said hey this is
happening police offic ERS judges
prosecutors politicians celebrities
media Moguls all played a part in it
Megan McCain said that literally
everyone in Washington knew what was
going on everyone was afraid of Jeffrey
Epstein this is this is something that
will bring everyone together and make
people understand hey uh the system is
rotten it's corrupted and it can't be
fixed until we deal with this one single
issue we've we've not only have heard
these stories of Epstein the Lolita
Express Madison cauthorne made some uh
some allegations Madison cauthorne was
right was right cuz we all saw as much
as you probably didn't want to that
video out of the Senate was The Heart
Building hearing room floor which was uh
very disturbing and I do hope they
decontaminate that building I mean that
sincerely I mean he should be arrested
what he did was worse than what 99.9% of
people on January 6th did and he should
be arrested and put in federal 100 well
I don't not beating a police officer
there's a couple people that did but
yeah well it is a desecration of the
space I mean most January six people
I've interviewed a lot of them as you
have and they're all I mean they were
there because they believe in the system
because they all had pocket
constitutions they thought it was real
and they were so shocked to see their
election stolen which obviously it was
and that they marched on the capital but
they were there to uphold the system and
some did it imperfectly and some got out
of hand of course but this guy is there
to degrade it to defile it on purpose
like there's no reason to do that in a
hearing room and to post it on the
internet like let's make this
distinction here as it pertains to
January 6 there were people who were
violent that's bad you should you should
be held criminally responsible if you're
attacking cops I agree with you Charlie
there were people there who were let in
by the cops but knew that something
violent was happening but more
importantly I have spoken with many
people who showed up an hour after any
violence to cleared cleared roads no
Gates doors wide open with cops smiling
welcomed them in and took selfies and
those people I've met two of them
they're going to prison for 18 months
and they said I show up an hour later
it's a clear sidewalk we walked up there
are people Milling about cops open the
door weird shrugging we we walk inside
for a few minutes we walk out no idea
anything ever happened next thing we
know the feds are at our door the the
these are not people who even as you
described tuger these are people who are
just there to see Trump speak and happen
to be in the wrong place at the wrong
time so how about no on that I mean when
is some honestly I mean I don't you know
want to put anyone in Jeopardy but like
until people say we're just not playing
along with this anymore obviously
Congress isn't going to help you know
the problem we talked before about
religion Christianity is like the
battlefield of the culture war and you
were talking about demonism and Satanism
creeping into the culture in a lot of
ways I think one of the problems with
Christianity is that it encourages
people to be subservient to a church and
then therefore subconsciously they
become subservient to a government like
why aren't they saying no well a man has
as many Masters as he does vices and the
reality is you're a slave to something
and if you choose to be a slave to God
as opposed to the government you will be
the most difficult possible man to
conquer but it's the way they Define God
you got to be aware that they're not
define God he told us who he was I think
and I think Ian
uh age I but but but I I don't disagree
with Ian's point but I think it would
have to be refined in that there are
people who masquerade pretend or don't
truly understand and would use Faith to
manipulate others I mean we see this in
government especially when Democrats
claim to be the real Christians but then
say the church is in favor of say
abortion or something like that yeah and
I'm obviously I'm speaking from a a
thoroughly Protestant perspective but I
don't see my reading of Christianity
just like the text does not at all
indicate loyalty to a church it
indicates fty to God yes and so I first
of all it's not incompatible with being
a citizen at all um I think Christians
make the best citizens actually and you
can absolutely support your government
and support your God but if it comes
down to it if your government is
actively opposing God you really do have
to make a choice between those two
masters and and I'll make a quick point
Sorry Charlie I'll make a quick point
and Shout out our good friend Bill Maher
because it's a point I've made
frequently that whether bill
acknowledges or not as an atheist his
moral framework is built on
judeo-christian values this country was
found he say that now he doesn't but it
but it's a fact Tom Holland wrote the
book called Dominion where he's an
atheist secularist who said that we all
have a Christian inheritance whether you
like it or not that's absolutely right
absolutely Bill Maher believes in free
speech he believes an innocent till
proven guilty all Christian values
Christian values and you know I uh uh
wanted to explore years ago why the
founding fathers decided upon these
amendments to the to the Constitution
and the framework as it was and you
learn a lot about how the Bible
influenced their views of what is just
and moral and so so just to it at the
surface reading you might say oh you
know Christians aren't supposed to fight
back against tyranny Exodus one The
Midwives to the Hebrews they disobeyed
the order of pharaoh where they said
throw all the babies in the river they
said no we're not going to do that and
God said dealt well with them it says in
Exodus 1 Daniel 6 Daniel disobeyed the
order says you can't pray anymore he
says nope I'm going to keep praying and
he opened up the window and prayed
proudly and it ended up in the lines
then in Acts it says you obey God not
man so look throughout Christianity we
have seen on hon ly one of the most
successful the most successful movements
against tyranny are when Christians are
brought to a Breaking Point Christians
can be very agreeable and then as soon
as that snaps Disobedience to tyrants is
obedience to God I want to shout out
Sheamus real quick when he said you
would be the most difficult man to
conquer and this is exactly why I think
there is such a a a tremendous push
against anything that is related to
Christianity because these are people
who follow God who obey God and you need
someone to be hold to a man because a
man can change the rules at any moment
that's right yeah well and and so you
guys I know you mentioned you're coming
at it from a Protestant perspective I'm
the resident Catholic here so I have a
different perspective uh on the church
but I I will say part of the reason I
appreciate you so much and the things
that you've said on air is because even
though you're an Episcopalian you're
somehow like the most Catholic
commentator on air I find the things
that you say about like economic Justice
and also social conservatism tend to
line up very closely with the the
political values that I have uh as a
Catholic uh but I would say that of
course as Christians we should be good
citizens and Obey Civil Authorities when
they are not asking us to do something
evil but as soon as you're commanded to
do something evil you have to resist
that yeah the scriptures are very clear
about that you obey God not and the
church tradition is is very clear about
that Tucker you made some very
interesting comments recently that has
been uh going viral all over social
media when you were specifically talking
about um UFOs and you you were
specifically talking about something
that is hard to kind of really
understand here I was wondering what's
your kind of take on all of this cuz I I
see this as a spiritual war do you see
this as a spiritual war what what are
your kind of core belief systems when it
comes to addressing the larger evils of
the system well I you know as I so often
do I spoke incompletely I didn't fully
explain myself um in the clip that
you're referring to which like eight
people have sent me uh in Outrage that I
basically said there are things that I
know that I won't say which of course is
not exactly right I don't know I mean I
can't prove it and I really do try like
say things that I really believe are
true and are provably so um and so
that's kind of my hesitance if I had
facts I would I would say them it's my
personal belief based on a fair amount
of evidence that they're not aliens
they've always been here um and I and I
do think it's spiritual that's that's my
view and and again it's not provable but
based on on the evidence I think I'm
abely well the military has been working
in this realm for a very long time they
have been also trying to to weaponize it
there's also a lot of crazy experiments
that they did with DMT hooking people up
essentially to DMT IVs having people go
off into the spiritual realm so there
there there if if you're not paying
attention you don't understand that
there's a larger kind of energetic uh
frequency in battle happening but can I
say one thing if the US government has
in fact had contact Direct contact with
these beings whatever they are I've
already told you what I think they are
and has entered into some sort of
agreement with them which is which is
the claim of of for people um I would
say whether they're right or wrong I
can't say conclusively but if that is
true I mean it's a very very very heavy
thing a lot of people say
interdimensional beings right I want to
ask are are angels and demons or how
would you describe these these beings
you know I these are again I'm getting
into the realm of conjecture so I just
want to say that flat out entity but one
thing I know for a dead certain fact
having seen it is that um there is good
and evil that we are being acted upon at
all times and I think every person can
feel that in himself I mean there are
moments when you are moved to do things
that are much better than you actually
are and that are also more evil and
destructive than you actually are you
are subject to forces from outside
yourself that is absolutely true now we
can argue about what they are but every
person in the room if he's reflective
will tell you yes I know what you're
talking about and so there are forces
that are not human that do exist in a
spiritual realm of some kind that we
cannot see and that when you think about
it sort of make you think live in an an
Farm being right and that's just that is
real okay and there's many artists also
talking about how essentially what they
do and their greatest works of art is
usually done through channeling of
course and and there is an aspect not by
the
way not that good yet um every by the
way every artist will tell you that
every artist that's something happened
that they're they're they're not
themselves that they just were were
doing their art and then something just
no but and it's not just Visual Arts
it's it's every creative act brings you
closer to something outside the human
real and you can feel it whether it's
woodworking or writing or painting a
painting or writing an opera or writing
a rap song or whatever anything that is
true and beautiful or anything that is
dark and destructive is almost certainly
a product of forces acting upon you and
you can feel it you created us to
participate in Creation with him to
participate in his creativity and make
things that's right and since everyone
here is cool I'll say this um with
respect to demons and spiritual forces
there's a a priest who is lzed towards
the end of his career he's relatively
controversial but he was an exorcist by
the name of Malachi Martin and one thing
he said about exorcism cases is that in
films you see all of these over-the-top
portrayals of head spinning and and
vomiting and he said when it comes to
things like vomiting and all of these
these uh Supernatural visual indicators
of possession that those are the cases
that are the most mild because the
Soul's trying to fight back and with for
of perfect possession the most dangerous
forms of possession you can't tell when
you look at the person because they're
perfectly content with the evil thing
they're doing and then you look at the
way people in DC act you look at the way
our political leaders act and you go is
it that much of a stretch to say some of
people and this is not some crazy
Outsider belief Jesus performs exorcisms
in the Bible like this is not something
that and does it make you wonder that no
doctor has ever been able to explain
where exactly schizophrenia comes from
and that we cannot treat it we can
suppress it but we cannot treat it and
there's no kind of Baseline for it at
all there science that has not
penetrated schizophrenia so like what is
that the other thing one of because and
that's because in my view is a you know
28y year old cartoonist who knows
basically nothing about the world but if
I would be so bold as to speculate on
this I think part of that is the problem
with psychology is it doesn't take into
account that the human person is a body
Soul composite and that you are not just
chemical reactions happening at the
level of the brain in a series of
tangled up pathologies that produce
certain behaviors in States Of
Consciousness you have a soul there is a
spiritual component to you that can be
acted on by outside spiritual forces
when I was younger I I you know 18 192 I
very much fell into this there is no
good and evil it's competing interests
some people think the other person's
evil because their interests don't align
and they different worldviews and uh as
I got older especially with the past
eight years I I've my my worldview
fundamentally changed and there's one
man I owe a great deal to for ex for
revealing to me the evils of the world
that's Adam Schiff he is a liar a
cheater a deceiver a manipulator I mean
I I I was I was so shocked to see this
guy on TV lie in the way he does to
destroy for and and I call him out
because it's an easy it's an easy name
to throw throw mud at but there are so
many people that I'm shocked to see
particularly on the left with liberals
and now the neocons who've joined them
who I am I'm I'm shocked when I'm like
these people know they're lying they
know what they're doing will drive us to
a path of Destruction for what logical
purpose none and let let me give you a
quick story when I was at Occupy Wall
Street this was a this was one of my um
formative moments
here I am 25 years old really still kind
of believing a lot of there you know
good and evil is subjective and I met
someone who worked for a major media
corporate press publication who
explained to me as they write and
support the movement they were nihilists
and so their intention was to watch the
world burn down and I'm not exaggerating
they said nothing matters you can prove
nothing so wouldn't it just be fun to
watch it all burn and I said no that's
horrifying if nothing matters make your
purpose and make things better and make
things
beneficial and make it flourish and
that's when I started to think to myself
this person's writing for a major
corporate press outlet and it starts to
come into into clearer picture for me as
I'm seeing this throughout my career
there actually are people who are
legitimate malicious evil whose
intention is to cause suffering to
others and I think Fair Point you look
at serial killers and other crazy people
there's there's real evil in this world
there's more sociopaths per capita in
Washington DC than anywhere else in the
world that's not an accident okay these
are the people that you put in charge of
your life and this is where I I I come
as as an anarchist and and once again
try to remind all you amazing people the
solutions are usually within you taking
personal responsibility for yourself if
you give the government even a niche you
give them anything they will absolutely
take it and abuse it for their own
personal benefit I want to get to
Sheamus's Point here really quickly
because what you talked about uh some
people talk about frequency some people
talk about energies some people describe
it as Souls I I I do agree you do have
an a free quency but you decide where
that frequency goes how it's affected
what its impact on the world it will
have and uh that choic is everyone's and
I think the more we start looking at
ourselves and how we could be better and
less government intervening in our lives
then the true change will happen in in
our society when we no longer will need
government let's let's talk about 2024
we've got polls claiming Nikki Haley is
is doing very well and gaining ground
not that I think she will defeat Donald
Trump you guys like Nikki that's right
there you go fan favorite no F you guys
AR fans and it's and it's unsurprising I
mean this somebody who goes on stage and
advocates for war and lies about the
intentions of of Russia as a pertains to
Ukraine she's an accomplished woman and
you should stop insulting her and V
ramaswami has a problem with women for
calling out facts that was a Chris
Christie quote by the way I don't I'm
kidding I'm kidding he said that at the
debate all right I'm however I I was
asked a difficult question last night
because I think I think it was Steve
Bannon who said Trump's going to choose
a woman and with the the polls that are
coming out there someone asked me would
you vote for Trump if he chose Nikki as
VP and would you guys vote for Trump
well that's the question that I asked
you specifically I I would not only not
vote for that ticket I would I would
Advocate against it as strongly as I
could wow wow yeah that's just that's
just poison I mean here's someone who's
actively opposed to the interest of the
country I grew up in who endorsed the
BLM riots and who is not is is not left
but is neoliberal in the darkest most
speaking of nihilist nihilistic way and
has no real popular support is like is a
creature of the oligarchs so yeah that
would be that would be reason to oppose
the ticket even Trump Haley is a nogo
Nikki Haley he would get assassinated
immediately if that were the case yeah
and by the way I just can't imagine a
world where that could happen that would
be so crazy I mean anything could happen
of course but picking Nikki Haley um
who's utterly treacherous and utterly
dismissive of like the interest of
Americans yeah it's a no-o for me uh but
it's a for Black Rock and State Street I
really do love her but but but but I
want to turn the question to to everyone
here and just really quickly who would
you guys like to see as Trump's VP as of
course he knows what he's doing probably
vice president I have I know what I have
the straw pole results but before the
straw pole results let's just go let's
go around who who do you want to see as
VP I'm a big fan of a ram Swami
Charlie I um I'm sitting next who I
think should be vice president me
I mean I agree with you I'd vote for
that I I I think Tucker makes a lot of
sense for vice president I've said it
publicly I'll say it privately I
mean I mean I but the case I I kind of
like vake I think he's one of those
people who everyone beats up on VI for
being he's a phony and all this stuff I
don't know I I've covered a lot of
campaigns going back to 1992 and I've
noticed this thing in many candidates
and I noticed it in him the process the
process of running for president and
speaking three times a day and having
people throw hostile questions in your
face causes you to change they all
change during these campaigns like for
real inside and I feel like V's
positions have gotten much more sincere
since the beginning of this like he I
watch him with Nikki haly and I'm like
this is a guy who's very offended by her
views like for real he's not attacking
her CU she's a woman he's attacking her
because he actually thinks her views are
terrible for the country he lives in and
I love that mhm so is that is that a no
you're not going to Tim no I mean it's
like the weather I can't control that I
don't think I'd be that great at it well
who do you want to see as VP so I I I
think you know we we we we talked a bit
about this for a long time and often
have entertained VI ramaswami but then
when Trump Carlson popped up we all kind
of lit up like that would be amazing but
I think it's I think it's because when
we were talking about DeSantis so long
ago it was because we were looking for
someone who was less the Wild Card Trump
is a very strong personality and we were
looking for something that was someone
that would be a stabilizing Force the is
is very much like that uh Ron I think
his campaign has kind of uh been very
poorly run I'm trying to be nice here
and uh then we look to Tucker Carlson
Tucker you've got your finger on the
poll probably better than anybody else
in in the country well that's I don't
know about that but I I do care about
the country I know the country pretty
well very well very well actually it's
like the one thing I know a lot about
and I I think that kind of disqualifies
me right there but can I just ask a
question since you all are so on the
internet and like I'm not that much um
you really get the sense that Ronda
Santos who I liked as Governor uh the
people who represent him online are the
nastiest the stupidest and the most zero
some people I've ever seen in my life
and I don't think that reflects him but
it's like this is kind of small ball and
by the way these purported conservatives
Ron DeSantis changed his View and I like
him okay I think he's been a good
Governor I just want to be clear about
that I know him personally I like him
but his donor Ken Griffin told him to
change his view on Ukraine from it's a
regional conflict shouldn't get involved
into it's a super important thing we
should send more money one donor got him
to change his View and all these
so-called conservatives are supporting
that like it's the most important thing
ever like who are these people and what
is their problem like what is going on
with them it it does reflect on Ron
because Ron should have fired the people
running his campaign a long time ago uh
look I I respect that he wanted to
launch his campaign on X on Twitter
space time and it and it failed
miserably this is a mistake and now
you've got uh look I know a lot of
people groan but a lot of people laugh
the high heel s you know boot Scandal I
mean who's giving this guy advice and
why does he keep taking it cuz I will
say it I will say it politically and and
policy wise we love Ronda Sanz he's done
an amazing job but his campaign is a
train wreck yeah well and and so I I can
speak to this just having experienced
some of the um you know uh so you're
suppor online that's literally what I'm
saying of course thank you um no so with
the the danta situation again like I
know people who work for his campaign
who are are good people who really like
but that said I have not gotten more um
like Angry Petty push back from anons
online ever for pushing back against any
politician than I have when I've made
comments about Dan santis that were
really pretty benign I remember when he
was uh announcing his campaign one thing
I said is look you know when I see Trump
tear Dan santis apart or make fun of him
it doesn't Thrill Me The Way him
destroying Jeb Bush thrilled me because
I think if both Trump and DeSantis are
successful that's good for the
Republican Party
they' and said that and then I said here
the reality about I should have been
agreeing with everything he was saying
in his his campaign speech when he first
announced and I was bored to tears and
they need to get somebody to help him
with his delivery so he can be more
charismatic because that matters to
people I think that's a pretty benign
piece of constructive criticism and I
was just flooded with angry replies from
his followers and it was so strange to
me because I've said far harsher things
about other Republican candidates and I
have not experienced even a small
fraction of the push they're matter at
you than Joe Biden don't get what is
that like and I by the way as someone
who who is uh generally liked Trump I've
made fun of and pushed back against
Trump too and my fans who really like
Trump enjoyed it they thought it was
funnier they agreed I made fun of trump
all the time that's okay he's a person
no one is God okay lighten up a little
bit yeah my my my conspiracy theory is
that the people online are actually
Trump supporters masquerading as disant
supporters to just make everybody hate
him I'm like it's the only explanation I
come on at a certain point you have to
realize you to like we're talking about
his campaign staff and and his and his
high level staff at a certain point you
have to realize what you're doing is
failing I mean polls are going down he's
being beaten by Nikki Haley in the polls
if you want to trust the polls I'm like
at a certain point do a 180 stop you're
it's not working but they keep doing the
exact same thing but but I'll tell I had
a realization the other day because I
saw this tweet from Laura lumer uh which
purportedly came from Christina Pasha
but it appeared to be fake and I tweeted
no there's no way this can be real
Christina Pasha then retweeted a fake
version
supposedly coming from Laura lummer now
this at this point it's clearly fake
because it was a manipulation on what
Laura had posted so I call that out
saying these people are the scumbags
they camea they claim the Trump people
are and I get this push back where they
say you seem to have ignored the fact
the Trump campaign did this first whoa
whoa whoa I figured it out Laura lomer
is not the Trump campaign she's Trump's
biggest fan she does a lot of work in
support of trump but she is outside of
the campaign and she is not on the same
level as Trump's campaign staff and
press secretary Christina Pasha foronda
santz is his second in command who is
acting on the internet as though she is
on the same level as Laura lummer is
despite Laura not being part of Trump's
campaign so and I'm saying this not to
be disrespectful to anybody what I'm
saying is if you are running a
presidential campaign but you think your
path to Victory is to argue with fans of
your opponent online you have put
yourself way below the standards of of
that Governor you're representing yeah
one thing I want to point out that might
be a possible uh explanatory Factor here
the the great and insightful Orin
McIntyre said this so I'll give him
credit but the disantis campaign has
effectively become a shelling point for
all of the elements within the
Republican party that just hated Trump
so even though disantis has great
policies because they see it as a very
us verse him type of thing a lot of
people in the Republican Party who we
would agree shouldn't have a place in it
have migrated to his campaign and I
don't think they've advised them well I
think that it is very clear that there's
some ineptitude going around in in the s
a campaign but that you brought up Tim
that there's some sort of malfeasance
that people are in there manipulating
the scenes like we have ai that could
just be twisting people's thoughts about
danas constantly with comments with
retweets AI could be retweeting other
AIS that are or even machine learning
algorithms that are like making him look
really bad on purpose or vice versa I
mean it's let's or he has autism but no
no but let's get into this let's get
into this um one of the scariest things
I think we're seeing now is the
potential for what uh I mean Steve Ben
talks about this quite quite a bit The
Singularity we are getting uh well let
me start from the beginning there's
something called Dead internet Theory Tu
you have you ever heard of this no I'd
be the last know this is this it's an
idea that he's flexing that he goes
outside by the way he's like you guys
look pal enough can you internet
questions for me so dead inet Theory uh
believes that around 2016 is when we saw
a shift from real people on the internet
into AI Bots and suck puppets sock
puppets are you know one person will run
50 accounts to try and manipulate public
opinion and uh maybe maybe Elon Musk is
working very hard to get bots off of X
to try and create a genuine conversation
but as we're now to the point where we
have these large language models and a
lot of them especially grock now grock
is new the potential that you are not
even talking to a person when you're
debating online is is nearing 100% I'm
curious what your thoughts are on this
on this AI future and with these fears
in
mind well I mean it's hard to sort of
ignore the Instinct that like we're
approaching something horrible and final
I mean I don't understand how you and
could in good conscious build something
like AI
it's so Tower of Babel it's so
transparently Genesis 11 it it's so
transparently insane and of course we
now reports that the people building it
or worshiping it like a god which
obviously it is and um it that feels to
me like the craziest most Reckless thing
people have ever done and I think the
chance that that ends in tears is 100% V
little and so but also it's like
technological progress I don't know
we've had quite a bit of it and this
country is become much worse in every
measurable way since I was a child with
much less technological progress so and
I'm sorry I know there we have tech
people I have friends who are
professional technologists and they're
very excited about technology but
where's the evidence that it's a good
thing go I I mean where's the evidence
even the public health has declined they
used to say well at least we'll cure
cancer okay but that's not happening
people are getting we have more cancer
actually more obesity more suici exactly
so where just just show me the place
where technology in the last 20 years
has made people
happier and I don't think there is such
a place so maybe we should rethink our
core assumptions about technology I
agree but I do think we have serious
cultural problems and I wonder if
perhaps the argument is a culture will
be destroyed through uh technology in
this way particularly Communications
technology it starts with the printing
press which we say was great then the
radio it was fantastic then television
oh how awesome and now the Internet it's
changed everything but it does seem like
it's becoming noise and static and pure
chaos from it I'm wondering if it is an
impossible solution or or if we've just
not found the solution it's a neutral
Force it's just like the atom bomb is
neutral if it's in the hands of evil it
will be used for
evil do you really think that because
here solve this mystery for me um
creativity pretty much died in the West
in August of 1945 when we bombed hoshima
and then Nagasaki so I don't know I
maybe I'm the only person who's
interested in this but the the death of
creativity in the United States is very
jarring to me that's true in literature
name three great novels written since
1945 in English oh you can't name 10
great Public Works projects since 1945
oh not possible something changed
fundamentally since we dropped that bomb
and I don't think I'm imagining it and
by the way if you have counter evidence
to wreck my theories please give it to
me but I do think something about the
Godlike powers of nuclear weapons
convince people they are God I think
there may be some spiritual force in
effect there but whatever it is that
moment changed this country in the
entire West forever and diminished it
forever and I grew up defending the
bombing of Japan with the atomic weapons
because oh you know we couldn't deal
with an invasion or whatever now I'm
thinking in what way how insane was I to
defend dropping a nuclear bomb on people
if you find yourself defending that
you're a freak but I but I but I'm
wondering if it's it's not the nuclear
bombs but television the expansion of
Television uh I've I've often half joked
that the 9s was the last decade and I
think it's probably due to the internet
the decentralization of of
communications through the internet
results in no cohesive visible culture
in this country you look at the 40s 50s
607s you see a unique culture that
exists in America of course after the
'90s with the explosion of the internet
now it's I I got to tell you we went to
the mall a couple days ago and this it
really does blow my mind that I see a
Hot Topic and I guarantee you Jack
Skellington is in is in the window
that's a 30-year-old movie still being
sold to kids who have no idea what it is
I there's a viral Tik Tok where a young
woman's wearing a Nirvana shirt and just
I don't even know what this is I just
buy it anyway it is it's almost like
television around that era does
something to creativity by homogenizing
everything but we don't understand this
I mean look the creative force is the
life force and by the way it's closely
related to the the sex impulse which
ultimately is a creative Force to create
new people that's exactly right so if
you see a decline in or a death of the
creative Force what you're looking at is
death of the culture Andor society and
there is no question movies are just one
manifestation of it we have seen the
death of the creative impulse in the
west and that is like an emergency a
tragedy a history changing event and
it's never acknowledged as you were
saying that it clicked for me it's
contraceptives it is it is the the it is
the development of reliable and
effective methods of artificial
contraceptives and their legalization
across the country I I head no it's true
no it's a reality because the most well
and this is something all Christians
believed a hundred years ago in in Prior
the one of the most intimate and
productive literally productive things
human beings do together you are
collaborating with God in the creation
of new human persons whose Souls will
last longer than all of the stars in the
universe and we took that and we turned
it into playtime we said this is for fun
this is for feeling good this is not
about making things and we thought that
wouldn't affect our psychology we
thought that wouldn't stri of our
creative impulse when we spit in the
face of our creator in one of the most
fundamental ways he asks us to
collaborate with him in the creation of
new things beauty let me make it a
little bit more secular though without
people having children they detach
themselves from responsibility from
purpose and from work and now we have
these videos of people being like I'm a
dink I just do nothing you've got
Chelsea Handler saying I wake up do
drugs and masturbate and then go back to
bed I don't do anything there's no
reason for creation I bet she doesn't
masturbate she she's too
soulless well for sure sure but my my
point is I agree around this point when
you start getting the lack of when you
have people who in intentionally do not
have children you look at a lot of these
videos and you see there there's a
through line people who don't have kids
lean a certain direction they're they're
they're not working hard for something
because they have they they they don't
have that responsibility I thought I
think it is TV man I think it's TV and
now video games and it's people there's
a difference between making television
and watching it and if you just sit
around and watch it you're not creating
you might be learning so you're you
might be creating neural Pathways but
really the creative
spark is within you or maybe it's just
modernity wait but where's the
technology in the last say 25 years
that's elevated people and made their
lives better and made them more fully
human I think internet can if you use
has it has it anywhere you name an
example of where technology and the and
I I will grant you antibiotics okay and
electricity great I
I have some questions about electricity
but good but fever give me an example
like as as this all sort of accelerates
right exponentially literally
exponentially the development of
technology has there been any place that
you can point to globally where it's
been a Force for good I think the
decentralization of Journalism with the
internet has blown the lid on the entire
liberal economic ord's plans that
they've had for the last 30 or 40 years
yeah that's good but that's pushing back
against the society that technology
created and and this is but this is the
point I wanted to make it's easy to say
oh look we're broadcasting live right
now how you know so many people but
Tucker's question what what has
benefited Humanity I can't say the
internet has because it seems to be at
best neutral because it's also been
weaponized by Deep State elements on X
on Facebook on Instagram on YouTube to
silence people at the exact same time
and and create fake narratives it
doesn't just silence them it it dumbs
them down and also uh bastardize them it
also promotes pornography especially
children it destroys their their
innocence so so I I would kind of agree
with with Tucker here when when it comes
to this and and a lot of this sometimes
has to do with short-term Pleasures over
long-term Pleasures but I think a lot of
it also has to has has has a lot to do
with with a larger chemical castration
that is happening systematically of the
average male if you look at sperm counts
they are dramatically going down the
average 22-year-old has this has lower
testosterone than the average
70-year-old in the 1980s that's not a
coincidence of course menit low or more
easy to be conquered and controlled and
dominated and enslaved there's a reason
that I think there's a larger biological
War out there and whether it's fought
with seed oils or high fructose corn
syrup or with Astic bottles plastic pfas
forever chemicals whatever you might
whatever you might call it there is a
direct attack on your testosterone on
your balls on your freaking sperm levels
on your masculinity if you're a male
there's nothing toxic about your Mas
we need to
Prior remember when we were kids and
they said don't eat Butterfinger and
Mountain do at the same time it'll lower
your sperm count we all got scared do
you remember that one yes I mean here we
are now and it's like definitively you
know the chem chemicals leeching into
your food through Plastics do this and
everyone's like oh is is it is it is it
really doing that that's like the
benefits out way the the consequen it
doesn't just give you Bill Gates moves
okay it destroys any kind of resistance
to the system he says as he's drinking
coconut water from a plastic bottle yeah
but I mean no disrespect he's going to
grow some coconuts no but we so you know
for us back at the studio we we bought
reusable glass bottles hey we're
recycling look at that reuse you refill
your glass bottle with filtered water
but also we want to reduce how much
plastic we have attached to the food
reading but mean I suggest one other
downside not to be dark about it but
technology enabled the creation of a
surveillance state that so outpaces
anything East Germany even attempted
that the net effect and ask yourself if
you thought this recently is that no one
feels free to express unimproved
thoughts even in private because you
know you're being listened to or you
that you could be listened to and what
is the effect on the human and the human
soul when there's no place for you to
honestly Express Yourself Liberty is uh
you know impossible without privacy you
have to have there was no door in your
bathroom would or no on your bedroom
would you feel free of course not that's
solitary confinement in prison so the
loss of our privacy is not some weird
esoteric thing the ACL used to car about
it's like it's it's foundational y yeah
um I I think that's that's absolutely
correct and one thing I I firmly believe
is that tyranny is fundamentally anti-
intimacy if there are people you trust
and have genuinely intimate
relationships with you can tell things
you can share your real Thoughts with
then you are a harder person to control
because other people are there to tell
you that you're not crazy for noticing
things that they're noticing as well and
what we have done with intimacy is
firstly we've taken it we've turned it
into a euphemism for sex and anytime
someone has an intimate relationship
with a genuine friend we make jokes
about them being homosexual with that
person or if it's a friend of the
opposite sex or even their spouse if
they have like a genuinely loving caring
relationship with their spouse where
they bear their souls out to one another
we see that as strange that should be
somebody you just use for sex and not
someone who you like actually have a
deep spiritual connection with and I
think that's part of why pornography is
so important to those in power is
because it strips one of the most
intimate people things people do of its
intimacy of carola rather than showing
too much of a person pornography shows
too little of a person it strips the
human dignity away from the subject and
again I will go back to contraceptives
it does it with contraceptives you're
not rolling the dice when you're with
this person you're not rolling the dice
and saying this is someone I'm willing
to bring life into the world with you're
making a strong case for the papacy I
have to say I've always made fun of it
they say that you're getting me we're in
the apocalypse or that we're entering
the apocalypse you want to hear the you
want to hear the strongest case for the
papacy I've heard by the way Tucker this
is from uh I believe this was Bellic and
he said part of the reason I know the
Catholic church is is the true church
founded by Jesus Christ is because no
organization runs so incompetently for
2,000 years could still possibly survive
well it's funny I I'm you know again I'm
coming in it from an i some of my
closest friends some of my closest
friends are Catholics but actually
that's true and there's so many things
that I love about the Catholic Church um
but you know I'm I'm not pro the pope
okay I'm just not and so a couple people
have pushed me in papacy or this Pope
both both probably probably both but
I'll just be honest I want to offend
anybody just very offended by this Pope
okay so I've said that to a couple
people close friends of mine who are
Catholic who said oh yeah we are too and
I was like well how they're more
offended than you talk yeah they're more
off exactly they're you know that's
insightful they're more offended than I
am and I said well okay I was offended
by the Episcopal Church I left and and I
oh I love not being in that church but
um they said no no no the church is far
bigger than this guy we've had a lot of
bad popes actually exact and and I love
that attitude just saying we're in this
thing called The Apocalypse I I think
right now it's we could we could be in
the end times and it's like the great
revealment really is what the term means
and it's like the truth we talk about
honesty and if you're going to hide and
have secrets is it righteous or just to
force your secrets into the open so that
now you're forced to be honest with like
a neural net and we're all honest with
each other at all times is that too far
cuz I kind of agree that Liberty but the
Liars what do you do I don't even know
what a neural net is but I want to say
conclusively I'm opposed to it yeah El's
working on it that's why in Christianity
you only want a loving God to know your
thoughts we and Nikki Haley wants to
know everything if an unloving thing
sees your thoughts imagine what would
happen a nural net would be like uh an
inter a brain computer interface where
you're sending commands and receiving
commands from machines in real time with
your thoughts I'm not going to be an
early adapter of that well that's the
danger of the of the AI and the
artificial intelligence as many world
leaders said whoever controls artificial
intelligence first will control the
world Vladimir Putin said the country
that leads an AI will be the ruler of of
the world with this technology
especially with its Perpetual growth
there's a lot of threats and challenges
for Humanity that we need to address why
doesn't someone blow it up like what
freaks me out most about AI is how
everyone's so passive in its rise in the
face of its rise it's like if you think
this thing is existentially dangerous it
could extinguish Human Society why
doesn't someone blow up the servers
everyone's like oh there's nothing we
could do and we're very concerned How
concerned are you it's not only that
there's also there's also a larger
possibility that that the AI could could
already be in charge we haven't thought
about that because if it is the people
in charge wouldn't be telling everyone
the AI is here guys they would be using
it for their own Sinister purposes so I
think we could be living in a situation
where the AI is having more an effect
more of an effect on our lives than we
could even realize right now I think you
can't blow it up because it's actually
you could you could knock out servers
but the data itself that writes the code
is decentralized well then it's an
autonomous being and it obviously is not
you can't hand control of human society
over to a non-human
like I don't I'm not you know I'm a
subgenius and even I get that so what
are we doing I think the code should be
open so that we can see what this
thing's doing at the very least but I
think of it as an inevitability like the
atom bomb like whoever gets it first is
going to control the planet for 50 years
this is the issue you have all of these
different companies basically agreeing
hey this thing's going to be really
dangerous but if we don't do it they
will right so we better be the ones in
control of it and you have governments
you can AR open sourcing the code is too
dangerous if they'd open sourced the
Manhattan Project and Hitler built it
first we'd probably all be speaking
German right now mhm so that's a very
real thing like secrecy is a valuable
tool in global domination and it's not
like you have to try and dominate but
like if you just sit back behind your
walls and wait someone's coming one day
we don't have walls is the thing we
don't even have that luxury we don't
have walls to sit behind we have pods I
I I I don't believe that there is a a a
practical solution and that that is
deeply worrisome because I don't think
people truly you really don't like we
it's past the point that we can control
it it we may we may be past the Event
Horizon the point at which the PO
towards AI is so great there's no
backing away from it we're being sucked
in faster and faster I think you can go
into it with these neural Nets a human
that understands the code can go into
the system be in the virtual realm and
reverse engineer the code you can see
what's happening and how it's being
written in real time and change it with
their minds it's I mean maybe I would
just do it with a keyboard man I'm not
going into that thing listen this is
this Ison musk's argument we must
integrate with the machine Le we get a
Terminator like scenario anyely think
this is going to end well I mean
honestly but but listen like this is the
scary people need to understand about
about the singularity event when AI when
it when it actually turns on when we
reach artificial general intelligence we
might be it's an and we might be there
and just not know it it's an it's a
point at which the machine itself be
exponentially improves itself so if the
rate of growth for the the computer
systems that we're building is say Moors
La it doubles every two years once we
reach the point of AI Singularity or I
guess you could call it artificial
general intelligence it's just straight
to the top right up to the point of of
near infin
where this machine is improving itself
learning faster and faster and
calculating faster and then it's beyond
our our comprehension like nearly
instantly so the people who created that
are evil I mean right and so why why are
they rich and Powerful I would I I would
say it's many many of them I I would
argue there's uh uh what I would refer
to as the banality of evil that it is a
commonplace Endeavor to get a job
working for a company that's devel
developing this and having no idea that
you are starting the fire which could be
the destruction of human individualism
I'm with Tucker the indifference from
people that could do something is
unbelievable to me I just I'm I don't
I'm not an expert on it at all and I'm
with Tucker I I don't understand accept
the possible threat but why why have we
not had some form of a
government-mandated pause on this thing
because it's not going to stop China
yeah okay so what what does that mean
that means that they are going to have
their own supercomputer that can then
kill their people the W glal work in
China hold on how are they going to
develop AI that they can control there
are also I'm I'm look I'm I'm just as
frightened about all of it as you guys
are but there are also certain
applications that are clearly far worse
that I don't think China is developing
that we are that we need to stop so for
example I saw somebody posting about an
AI dating bot on the internet where men
who are too scared to talk to women
start talking to this thing and it's
trained to tell them what they want to
hear and that is that is going to
destroy so many lives that should be
immediately stopped from happening
authorities were interested in promoting
the common good that would be banned you
would not be able to sell that you would
not be able to make that we actually
have a a a big breaking story about this
and James O'Keefe waiting on Deck to
come and talk to us about it but I I
know that Tucker you want to hang out
and keep talking about this of course
then uh Ian would you mind uh swapping
out with James yeah but I'm going to
come out here and rub your shoulders at
some point all right so we love you J
but but this is actually perfect timing
James o'keef has a big story on IBM
these are these are computer companies
and their views on woke gender ideology
so he's waiting right now if you want to
run back and send him out and then he
can James can probably provide some
insights into us as to what these
companies are doing Round of Applause
for Ian thank you
[Applause]
Ian
Z good and good for you so this actually
is perfect timing in this conversation
as we know that James has been putting
out these videos under Undercover videos
or I believe leaked videos from IBM
talking about their gender ideology
Commandments and mandates and uh let's
uh hopefully he's out here James
O'Keefe are they going to do he's going
to there he
is James O'Keefe
everybody what is that man it's a
bulletproof vest it's a bulletproof vest
so so James you got a few enemies James
you heard what we were talking about
hello hi Tim thanks for coming man nice
to see you Tucker was asking about the
the people and the companies behind the
creation of these computer systems in Ai
and I said actually James has some deep
insights into what these companies do
yeah this this um well you said it today
Charlie about the Ten Commandments
within IB on pbd show I connected all
the stories together because they're two
seemingly unrelated stories so IBM
announces all this AI growth and their
stock goes up and then James O'Keefe
reveals that they have the Ten
Commandments that govern the values of
IBM and so basically IBM is telling you
that they're creating a woke super
weapon this is so demonic no no that's
basic and exactly and the Ten
Commandments are not you know the 10
that were revealed to
Moses they're they're literally like
that white people can't be racist that
black people can be do nothing wrong
that Ali sh it's literally says quote
understand only white people are racist
it is the W is that an exact quote
that's an exact quote it is the woke
anti-racist decalogue is what and you
said something pretty profound you said
that eventually AI will make this the
actual ten commit that's what I'm saying
yeah I mean if if you think for a I mean
there're you yal Harari has already said
that artificial intelligence is going to
rewrite its own religion for Bible
stories that quote make more sense for
people wow yeah I mean there're of
course they need to go after the actual
Ten Commandments it's not going to be
honor your mother and father it's going
to be honor your lesbian black Master
yeah yel Harari also said that the era
of Free Will is over um that's the type
of centralized thinking that these
individuals are
all
you you said that they were creating a
God they're creating a demon they're
creating a devil a false
god for sure no it's a it's a demon but
there but what's so interesting is at
least you know in the the whole
management carfuffle over there at aihq
um the letter that got him bounced
briefly from the helm said these people
are are like you know dancing around the
proverbial fire worshiping this thing
and I'm like of course they are of
course they rituals attacked yeah they
have the golden
C just just to go off but it's important
the their stated goal yal herrer uses
Bible stories all the time that's what's
so creepy he talks about like the flood
he talks about the Tower of Babel they
since Nimrod tried to create the city of
Babel in Genesis 11 they've been trying
to reconstitute a Oneness of the
government and a Oneness of the world
they think artificial intelligence will
allow to let it's a one world government
that they have always been after what
they're going to do it through that's
why God scattered the people Babel means
god confuses Babel God confuses because
God does not want a One World Government
he wants Nations and now you add that to
the fact that a lot of people think
especially politicians like nahu that
believe that we're in the end of times
and when you see his conversations that
he has with Elon Musk especially when it
comes to artificial intelligence a lot
of things start to come together when it
comes to the time that we are in right
now that is going to be absolutely
decisive for Humanity we could either be
totally free or totally enslaved and
that decision might not be ours I I want
to talk about one of the first
iterations of artificial intelligence a
lot of people say this is not true AI
fine we don't got a nitpick on it but
Sheamus brought it up these these these
AI girlfriends that have been popping up
all these different apps where they
whisper sweet nothings into the ears of
young men to confuse them to pull them
away from from reality the scary thing
about it is people the these young men
they're they're on their phones and they
think they're just having a chat on
their phone you're not behind this AI is
a singular machine a singular entity
whether you want to believe it's it's
it's some kind of conscious being demon
whatever it is a single entity and each
of its fake girlfriends that is talking
to these young men is like a tentacle
coming out of it so these young men they
think they're they're being wooed by a
siren towards the great seas to die and
it is a gigantic demonic Beast luring
them to them but I just it's so lonely I
mean I believe in smell very strongly if
if I can't smell you you are not real
and so I I mean that you know and I
don't understand how people could fall
for that like in the end it's some
computer generated image it's utterly
fake like how it's like sadder than a
sex doll let me get needlessly uh
scientific for just for Ian because he's
not on the stage anymore there's this
really cool thing called a laser induced
plasma Channel now the one day this
military guy is like hey I would really
love to strike a guy with lightning with
a gun how do I do that well the problem
is lightning travels in the path of Lee
resistance so they got an idea they use
an infrared laser I'm probably getting
this way wrong but follow bear with me
anyway you you use an infrared laser to
charge the air in a straight straight
line izing the particles which creates
an easier path for electricity they
could then point a cannon and fire a
bolt of lightning essentially it's a
waste of energy so it didn't really work
out but the reason I bring this up is
for fun but mainly because young men are
having a hard time meeting girls I mean
especially with the me too stuff and not
an America Fest but yeah not an America
Fest America Fest is great and that's
why people should come to things like
this to meet people but imagine I agree
you know all of those challenges of Teen
Angst and it is not easy to to live I
mean this is just reality you have to
you have to strive you have to struggle
you have to fail and pick yourself back
up but Along Comes the Candyman who says
ignore all of that and I can satisfy all
your deepest emotions with this machine
right here and so unfortunately a lot of
young men they might think to themselves
you know I will try and meet actual
girls and get a real girlfriend but you
know I'll just use the F for now then
eventually they develop antisocial
behaviors they never meet people they
never develop those skills by the then
they're 20 years old and they have no
idea how to even talk to someone but
more importantly the great opportunities
to to meet someone when you're young in
your neighborhood used to be Church your
families and communities would meet uh
Public Schools I'm not a big fan of but
also a way that people would meet and
the workplace now we're working from
home now young people are are using
these apps and and they're not even
communicating anymore if we get to the I
mean we when we're talking about these
AI girlfriends as this just I just view
this as a tremendous evil understand
that dead internet Theory whether anyone
wants to believe it's true or not is
coming true factually before our eyes
because we we're looking at AI Bots
communicating with us of course
eventually now Twitter is integrating
grock at at what point does grock start
actually posting things and
communicating with people and at what
point does someone create a bot using a
paid script from GPT or something to
make Twitter accounts or X accounts to
communicate with people and then you're
there you're you're you're you're in the
fake world and we may already be
there does anyone still think it's
important to go outside and be with
animals yes yeah this is why we moved to
Virginia cuz now I have a family of deer
that live on my lawn it's so important
turkeys you'll learn more from them than
you will from Gro trust me chickens we
got a lot of chickens and chickens are
Bas a so we're we're very great but you
were describing Tim what better way to
depopulate a population than to do
exactly that what you're describing and
uh you know take Andrew Tate out of his
business so James walk us through
because this is some of the greatest
work and I just have to say this James
O'Keefe and Tucker Carlson have both had
challenging
2023 and I think I speak for all of us
we're so blessed and thankful that
they're back and fighting stronger than
ever right Tim it's amazing to have you
guys on stage together if you think
appreciate it if if you think about it
the regime did whatever they did I
think I have strong thoughts on that but
they're both stronger than ever because
they're both threats James we love you
and we support you tell us about this is
one of the most important stories you
have published in quite some time thank
you Charlie um thank you Tim and nice to
see you again Tucker great to see you
jam um I I I think that this story is
remarkable because usually there's a
couple people that maybe come to me now
there's been 150 people within IBM that
have come forward
150 and U I'm going to break something
right on your show here well I'll post
it on X so I guess I'll break it on X
and also on your show and this slide
says how does whiteness work this is an
IBM internal document I I talked to you
a little about it Tucker but it's the
red hat which is the subsidiary of IBM
and it says quote whiteness constructs
the game hides the rules then rigs the
game over and over again it's this it's
this slide that they give out inside IBM
and so there's really kind of an
explosion of whistleblowers coming
forward it's very encouraging and I
think that uh that could have a real
effect in 2024 I think the Whistleblower
is going to be very important in 2024
people on the inside with access to
what's happening I'm fairly optimistic I
got to be honest I mean with what you're
saying especially but we just have to we
have to be vigilant almost like the
first person you know you has to take an
extreme leap of faith and then everyone
else will follow but this is the sort of
whistleblowing in in numbers in in big
numbers I've I've never seen that before
and it's very encouraging to me but
someone has to come forward first and
that person is still within IBM IBM deep
throat is still there so I'm very
encouraged by that Charlie because
usually it was a couple people but it's
hundreds and I think that that's going
to be a a taste of what's to come and
the CEO has responded right
was on an all staff meeting a foreigner
who became an American Arvid Krishna he
said if you if you hire you know white
people or there's too many Asians will
dock your bonus and terminate you so
then he gets on an all staff Call last
week and he says there's this video that
came out okay of me and I said these
things and he's talking to tens of
thousands of people and he says don't
give this any Oxygen don't give this any
response and that was recorded and
leaked and published yeah so this CEO is
telling everyone inside the company
don't respond to this so I don't know
what they're what they're going to do
now they can't fire a 100 people this is
building culture and the message James
you've spread for a long time of be
brave has reached a lot of people and if
everyone holds that within their hearts
that they will always be brave and S for
what they believe in we need not worry
about this in 10 years but that's that's
hoping and in numbers I think people
need to do it in numbers we if anyone's
watching to connect all this together we
need more whistleblowers than these AI
companies right now we need
whistleblowers right now in these AI
companies to come forward with what's
really going on how advanced is is this
technology that we don't know enough we
have like you had one didn't you Tucker
didn't you have a Google whistleblower
that said it already reached Singularity
yeah and um yeah it just it's been
happening like so many Trends in our
society in slow motion and you sort of
see it and you register alarm and then
like deep ominous dread and then you
sort of move on to the next unfolding
crisis and it doesn't feel like anyone
can pause long enough to address any of
them and they just sort of moving
inexorably forward almost autonomously
and if you put it all together you're
like what are we watching here we're
watching like an actual pivot point in
history and I don't think I'm being
alarm I'm not an alarmist by temperament
I have a sunny disposition I think and
um but I don't have I don't see you can
reach any other conclusion from that
well it it's really horrifying there's
this line in there that you mentioned
about what whiteness does not no no
they're not saying what white supremacy
does or what white racism wh constructs
the game hides the rules rules then rigs
the game over and over again racial now
just think about this it's a racial it's
a blatant racial attack so they'll say
things like this they'll say whiteness
is evil they'll say we need to eliminate
whiteness and you have to pay attention
to them when they accuse you of things
when our buddy Michael nll said we need
to eliminate transgenderism they said oh
he's not attacking the idea of
transgenderism he's promoting genocide
which of course he was not okay so if
they think saying we need to eliminate
transgenderism means you actually want
genocide what does it mean when they say
they want to eliminate whiteness well
they' expained called for it they've
celebrated the fact I mean the president
of the United States did that I'm
looking forward to the day when there
are fewer whites when they're in the
minority well what is that I mean to to
call for any group to become a minority
is such a a sickening unfathomable well
especially in a country where they told
us for my entire lifetime that
minorities are by definition mistreated
and oppressed in this country so by
their definitions being a minority in
America is a threat to your life and
they're celebrating a group becoming a
minority it's like what what we're all
too embarrassed to say so but that's
like genocidal language they're not just
calling for it they're actually doing it
especially when you look at the the the
numbers when you look at the propaganda
that's in every TV show that's in every
commercial that's in every movie you
can't ignore it it's either overt or
subliminal they've they've forgot
telling a good story they don't do that
anymore it's all just pure ugly nasty
propaganda that is meant for you to be
hated on because of the way that you
were born which is
crazy big ways to reduce a population
from a majority to a minority it's
contraceptive abortion encourage people
to you know find ways to for them to not
have children and also to bring in many
many other people from outside the you
are in the state where the great
replacement is happening every day
there's 15,000 people that they're
bringing into Arizona to replace you
they want Arizona to be less white yep
and as it's less white they get more
power here's the funny thing is V
ramaswami says this and the media
immediately comes out and says oh
conspiracy theories conspiracy theor
series and then what happens anybody
who's paying attention sees the video
from Joe Biden saying we want it to
happen there's a video I believe it was
from Van Jones saying there effectively
what we are asking is for white people
to accept becoming a minority and the
Castro Brothers which I think is the
best example they are on like Face the
Nation in this long interview and
they're like you will be calling the
electoral votes for Texas because Texas
is becoming more Hispanic and the
interviewer says well what what do you
mean and they're like well yeah I mean
obviously Mass migration is a benefit to
the Democrat Party and Michael Anton had
the most powerful piece where the way
the Democrats respond to this is that
it's not happening and it's good that it
is The Parallax uh what is it called the
celebration Parallax you're allowed to
celebrate it but you can't be critical
of it yeah exactly you're if you write
an article you can get published in
vox.com saying it's so good that whites
are no longer the majority but if you
write the same article that says maybe
it's not a great thing that whites are
the majority they call you a white
supremacist they're no longer no no not
only that they say it's not happening
they're saying it like wait wait wait so
is it happening or is it not happening
but why why are people putting up with
it I mean one of the reasons this
doesn't happen to any other group is
people are like no you can't do that you
you teach my kids that that they're evil
because their skin color I'm going to
flip out in the pr I'm going to punch
you out like you mention no other group
would put up with that for one second
Tucker you are correct we had a father
in uh Lowden County Virginia which is
only it's literally about 30 seconds
away from where we're currently at who
showed up to challenge the system and
they they they arrested him I I don't
think the question is why why are people
putting up with it it's right now I
think you'll find that this faction of
people whatever you want to call it the
right I guess the media would refer to
it is are reasonable calm and trying to
work within the mean like their means to
be to do things procedurally and
correctly I also think a lot of people
especially white Christians they're
resisting identity politics they don't
want to go to that next step but that's
where it's heading I mean it's going
there quickly I mean white
identitarianism is going to happen and
they want it to happen well they're
creating it and I I speak for myself as
someone who's 54 group in a totally
different country I don't want to
identify as white I don't even like
thinking about that stuff I like
thinking about how people really are I
don't like thinking of them as members
of groups yep and they're pushing it
they're like everyone has an identity
everyone's a member of an identity group
except the majority who are despised and
we're trying to make them into the
minority but you're not allowed to
organize as a specific as your identity
and it's like they're they're not only
encouraging it they're guaranteeing its
emergence and and financing it in in
Ukraine with our tax dollars
Jes because are bations we're talking a
racist artificial intelligence that is
going to have Godlike power that's going
to be woke that's going to push their
own views of equity they could do that
in so many different manipulative ways
what was some of the biggest things that
you saw in this latest drop and what are
the implications here well I I think
this this Ten Commandments I think
Charlie said it can you go over some of
them yeah I will I'll pull them up right
now this is this is something something
called red hat which is a subsidiary and
by the way just so we're clear they call
it the Ten Commandments they're directly
trying to appropriate the decalog which
is the basis of Western Civilization Ten
Commandments this is an IBM internal
document leaked to to uh OMG from
multiple sources after the first person
came for amazing stff I'm going to read
this openly acknowledges privilege and
systemic racism exists never question
the reality of our black friends rejects
the idea that race is political accepts
that white people are responsible for
dismantling racism understands only
white people can be racist knows the
black community owes us nothing requires
acknowledgement repair of inable
mistakes is never rooted in white
saviorism sees the black community as a
group of individuals does not seek
recognition or praise for a job well
done SE sees the black community is a a
group of individuals well this is the
first thing that stood out to me so for
examp Community yeah also don't be a
white Savior and we're saving so you're
not allowed to say that blacks are 13%
of the population yet they internal
logical incoherence of that is so insane
you're dealing with dumb people that's
one of the things we never say like
whoever wrote that's like a oh my
gosh I'm so glad you said that because
this is this is something I've been
thinking about there are really complex
difficult decisions that the wisest most
virtuous most healthy well-rounded
person you've ever met in your entire
life that anyone you know has ever met
in their entire life would not be
qualified to make and they're being made
by stupid people they're being made by
idiots aggressive and I would like to
point this out um there is only actually
one person of color on the stage and it
is in fact
lukow you may be asking yourself how is
a blond white blueeyed dude a person of
color well according to the coalitions
for communities of color Slavic
individuals people from Poland for
instance are people of color so here is
a guy this makes no sense I have a card
I use it all the time what really this
is what really doesn't make sense to me
I was talking earlier about how tyranny
is fundamentally anti- intimacy and you
read something on that list which
perfectly exemplifies that we never
question the lived realities of our
black friends if you never question
someone reality they are not your friend
that's not what friendship means
friendship means you keep each other in
check when somebody says something that
you don't think is true and you
genuinely care about them you say that
actually doesn't map on to anything that
I've seen in the world let's hash this
out let's see what the truth is let's
find it together because that's what
friends do there's a really great Point
let me let me ask you if uh let's say uh
your buddies driving a car and you're in
the uh passenger seat and they're about
to drive off a cliff if you decide to
hop out of the car and say nothing
because you don't want to question their
realities are you being a good friend or
are you a good friend if you grab gra
the wheel slam the BRS on and say dude
you almost d drove off a cliff mhm well
it's infantilizing for sure but you're
treating them like children but you're
also anyone you don't question is by
definition like the godhead yep because
like what you know there's only one
entity that who's Beyond question that's
God himself so there is this religious
quality to it washing the feet
worshiping and whenever you do that to
other people they should be very nervous
and I I have at least one black friend
who was like the BLM stuff in the
aftermath all these Christian churches
worshiping black people was like I don't
like that at all that freaks me right
out this was a it was a it was a wild
experience for me when I first went to
Occupy Wall Street so this is we're
talking 12 years ago now and you know I
I I grew up in Chicago everybody knows
Urban liberal story and all that stuff
and we we hated this idea of judging
someone based on the color of their skin
instead of the content of their
character amen I go to New York City at
the start of Occupy Wall Street they
started Luke was there too so Luke
definitely knows this they started off
with something they called the general
assembly where everybody would sit down
and they would all you know raise their
hands to speak and then they would do
twinkle fingers they called it if you if
you liked cuz clapping was offensive to
people who couldn't hear or whatever
they had something called Progressive
stack that meant if you raised your hand
to speak but you're a white man bottom
of the list because white men are
privileged so they would actually look
at people and say can I get anybody
who's not a white man you can't speak
and if you look like one You' have to
shout out something about why you were
actually a minority I knew there was one
instance where a guy raises his hand and
they go anybody who's not a white man
and he goes I'm gay and they go okay you
can talk now that that qualifies one of
the most shocking things I ended up
seeing which is a real wakeup call for
me was when they created something
called the spokes Council this is where
they decided the general assembly is
inefficient let's have a better more
efficient model of decision-making by
breaking everyone up into different
groups based on the job you do if you
work on the website you're part of a
website group if you work on cleaning
sanitation you're sanitation group and
of course let's have a group for only
black people a group for only Asian
people a group for only Mexican people a
group for only women and they actually
decided to have political voting power
on resources based on your race or sex
and then there was a moment one day I'm
walking on the side of zucati Park and
there was a black man sitting up on this
planner and he said these people are
nuts what do you think the Press is
going to say when they find out they're
segregating everybody based on race to
make their decisions but they just
destroyed their own movement I mean I
was I'll be honest I was I was annoyed
by Occupy Wall Street but I was kind of
sympathetic to the core idea that you
have this massive series of financial
crimes in 08 and not one person is
punished and that actually the real scam
is economic they're they're looting the
country and someone needs to call out
the banks on this in finance World in
general Occupy Wall Street was totally
eclipsed by identity politics which I
believe was you know the antidote like
the banks got together and the people
who benefit from banks are like oh let's
just pit them together based on race
like this is a widely held Theory but
for the occupied Wall Street people
themselves to be embracing identity
politics undercuts their whole argument
it was subversion it was subversion I I
I met Luke there and you ask yourself
everybody everybody here knows Luke how
how does someone like Luke Luke and I
come together and it's because
originally it was exactly as you
described yeah it was people from the
left it was people from the right there
was daily marches against the US Federal
Reserve there was a lot of Libertarians
there's a lot of people who were
representing the larger ideas of the Tea
Party a lot of ROM politics yes and then
and then this Coalition of individuals
from the left and right scared the crap
out of the ex then they sent in crazy
people that's how I got to know Tim
because me and Tim were at these no we
were at these spokes Council meetings
and we were like these people have lost
their freaking minds they're freaking
insane they weren't here on day one they
came in here and they're literally
saying black people got to stay here
white people have to stay here we're
like this is this is this is
stupid this makes no sense at all unless
you're trying to subvert and destroy it
from the inside and I think that's
exactly what happened and then the
corporate media said we got to obsess
about race because this is how you
destroy populist movements and this is
why we keep talking about race over
when it's the
simp that of not be a issue we should be
talking about the larger things and
there are more amazing things in life
not just a superficial that
doesn't matter I told Steve Ben and I
wish he came to Occupy Wall Street and
and and helped because that first week
was so different from what it turned
into there were I I remember meeting you
know a couple and they were they were in
their 60s with an American flag and they
were upset about the bank ballots and
this and subversion and I think what
happens is it's very easy for liberals
to infl trate in a city like New York
and it's very difficult for
conservatives to to stand their ground
in such a place and it's not a theory
Tucker I mean you can see that the
people that run Wall Street they love
the woke stuff like Larry fank because
then we never talk about income
inequality or wealth in the woke smoke
screen is is a protection racket for
them and they're paying half the taxes
yes I mean like why does no why did no
one I mean why is it twice as virtuous
to invest as it is to go to work every
day we tax the things we want discourage
and we don't tax the things we want to
encourage that's why cigarettes are so
expensive so if you're taxing investing
at half the rate as you are working what
you're telling me is it's twice as
virtuous to invest but is it I don't
know that it is I kind of admire people
who go to work every day like what what
is this and it's not even typical
investing right let's be honest this is
this is mass this is using other
people's money OPM like hard by the way
they're using Labor's money Tucker as
you know they're using teacher and
firefighter and police officer money and
getting 3% management fees and 30% of
The Upside by the way they don't pay any
tax on any of the earning they just say
oh you know we can't get rid of the
carried interest loophole and they have
this whole insane tax scheme designed
and I just I I wonder what wealth are
they actually creating or are they just
moving trillions of dollars of money
through a cheap kind of a cheap
instruments and taking taking 3% 4% off
the top but the woke this is what's
important we have to realize it Occupy
Wall Street was so scary to them because
it was diverse because it was by
partisan is that they H know Tim do you
actually think that Goldman Sachs said
go send in the identity politics people
I believe it like do you think that
there was a meeting at Goldman Sachs
where they said go bring in the NYU
trans like race people to go distract
them from talking about bank bailouts
not Goldman Sachs whatever but uh
powerful political interests this is a
fact there were people who were on
salary at large Progressive nonprofits
who were at Occupy Wall Street on paper
getting money from a nonprofit and
paychecks and the funny thing is when
this was accurately reported and
sometimes inaccurately reported they'd
say there the people down there are
getting paid by insert nonprofit who
receives money from say George Soros all
the activists would go I didn't get my
Soros check and I'm like dude John over
there works for this nonprofit that is
literally a progressive voter
registration nonprofit and he's
organizing the assemblies right now yes
that is literally happening and so
perhaps it was as simple as hey guys
here's an opportunity we better harness
it and it and it and it bumbs me out to
think the reality of Occupy Wall Street
was progressives being smarter and
faster than the populist right and you
you look at the stated positions of like
the open Society Foundation George Soros
it conveniently ignores wealth
inequality income inequality home
ownership it's like open borders and
racial transformation and trans stuff
it's like wait hold on a second George
Soros are you afraid that there might be
a real movement to go go take and tax
your $2 billion Foundation that doesn't
pay any taxes and is being used to you
know subvert and infiltrate the country
country but I think what has happened is
especially post Floyd is that every
major company is fine doing a $50
million check to some CRT Dei company as
long as we don't talk about the fact
that young people can't buy homes Larry
thinkink is terrified that this audience
or just Republicans Democrats young
people all across the country will unite
and lock arms and say why is it that we
can't buy homes and we're talking about
you know people's pronouns yeah that's
right can I sure I I I just want to say
this before you jump in uh I firmly
believe and you know I've changed my
positions uh obviously since I first
started with political commentary like
10 years ago I used to be just a very
like Diehard uh total free market guy
and I've moved on that I believe
property rights are extremely important
but part of the reason that I believe
that that's true is because people who
own property are a lot more difficult to
control and push around
and the issue with Communism and the
issue with Hyper capitalism even though
they express themselves very differently
and even though under communism you have
many horrific instances of people being
slaughtered uh I don't mean to down
plainy that but one of the the same
economic issues you see with both of
those is that all of the property ends
up centralized in the hands of a small
group of people who have control over it
so of course uh in a communist country
that's the party members and in a
capitalist country that doesn't have the
proper regulations in place that's the
capitalist class and you're average
person ends up without property so what
we need to do is structure our
regulations so that the largest number
of people possible can own property I
think that's the way that you have a
flourishing system I'm hopeful if you
own nothing you're not going to be happy
no right it's the opposite of what the
world economic Forum says what the world
economic Forum uh PR the principle
they're operating under is actually
derived from a quote from Harriet Tubman
I freed many slaves I would have freed
many more If Only They knew they were
slaves the inverse is what the world
economic Forum wants to introduce take
from them the knowledge of their freedom
and they won't miss it
are people so pissed off is the pendulum
now swinging in the other direction yes
cuz that's what I'm seeing they have to
indict Trump right because for years the
media could just say this person's
racist this person sexist this person's
homophobic and that was enough to
destroy that person's career but it
didn't destroy Trump and so because the
media no how no longer has the ability
to shut people up the state actually has
to come in and shut people up and you're
right it's making people angry stuff is
not just in um IBM it's in everywhere
yeah I'm getting the messages from all
the people inside all the companies so
it feels like whatever pressure it was
to adopt the Dei now it's just the
pendulum swung is that happening it's
The Bravery I mean how about we just
talk about the hard numbers of these
Disney movies and what did they lose a
billion dollars in their last releases
the latest Marvel movie was the lowest
grossing out of anything that they've
done so far yeah get what go broke can
we get a round of applause for
that lost a billion dollars on its films
on on I think what is it the last 10
films lost a collective billion the the
latest MCU movie was which was the
Marvels was a was lower grossing than
the Incredible Hulk in 2008 which is
considered to be their worst I think
people are just saying we'll find
something else we're done with it it's
kind of remarkable that some of the
greatest victories come from people just
being like I'm leaving it's just that
simple yeah they just say I'm not going
to look you know what I always used to
say whenever they would make these video
games that were all woke or whatever I'd
say hey that's great I'm really happy
for you that you got your video with the
your video game with the pink cared
woman I'm not going to buy it you know
but you do your thing and then it turns
out nobody else wanted to buy it either
but so James you have other companies
reaching out to you yes constantly you
usually on Signal or on our website just
non-stop Banks institutions I mean I
prefer video because I think documents
are not as powerful but it's non-stop it
just seems like it takes one and then a
crescendo you and you know this just
give them a camera and have them ask the
HR person about the document right then
you get a video there's a lot of this
like I have a mortgage I have a wife I
have a kid this it's it's always these
comp how do you respond to that it's
tough I mean I I it's I don't have a
mortgage and kids not yet but it's tough
to empathize um the the one individual
was very uh inspired by that one clip
you talking about very powerful the
pastor was there was a minister talking
to me about how afraid he was he should
resign from the ministry I don't I'm not
qualified to to advise the minister and
I said to the person what I say is
what's the worst thing that can happen
to you if you tell the truth and he goes
gee I I never thought about it that way
and individual with an IBM had seen that
clip and also saw the Elon Musk you know
Fu Bob speech and Elon Musk you know IBM
and Disney canceled advertising and and
the individual let's call them IBM deep
throat said what's the worst thing that
happened to me because because because
it kind of eats at you if you're seeing
something horrible and you're go you're
just doing the job for the paycheck and
the pension you know the wor that just
tears at your soul so you're you're
confronted with this horrible decision I
either do this job and I can't live with
myself or I tell the truth and I lose my
job and what I'm seeing is the
trajectory of people you know what I'm
going to tell the truth and lose my job
the worst thing that could happen to you
if you tell the truth you'll be set free
and and I feel like I feel like Tucker
and I that's Christianity absolutely the
truth will set you free that's right the
truth shall set you free and sometimes
the worst thing being free is actually
the best thing but they don't see it
that way because they got the mortgage
and the job and the roof and maso's
hierarchy of needs they have to have
food shelter you know Etc and it is and
it is hard it is scary I can respect
that
very difficult Doki said uh your worst
sin is that you have destroyed and
betrayed yourself for nothing and when
you when you think about that quote when
you look at the situation that a lot of
people are in they think they're making
the right decision for themselves and
their mortgages and their families right
now but but in reality they're making
the worst decision for their future for
their children for this country as of
course all these little decisions
everyone saying I'm just doing my job
that keeps adding to the initial
destruction as this country is being
sabotaged from within and it's only
being sabotaged with our acquiescence
with our participation in it with us
voting for it with us clicking and
liking and giving our money to these
creatures that serve essentially Satan
the these people don't serve you don't
care about you you you need to make sure
every dollar you spend goes towards a
good cause you need to download Public
Square and shop at businesses that
support your values our values and we
that's one simple simple way cuz maybe
all you're going to do is buy a you know
I don't know barbecue pulled pork but
you're supporting a company that
believes in this country I want to plug
something else something I just became a
member of and you guys should too and
Tucker you've had a crazy year Tucker
Carlson Network people can become
members too and get access to your
content thank you yeah I I want to build
something that can't be canceled but may
I say something about standing up and
you know taking the abuse for doing that
um I I do think it's high stakes for a
lot of people and all my kids are grown
and I've already been through the cycle
of you know being poor Rich poor You
Know Rich again um and so I don't find
that as scary but I do think if you've
got kids in the home it's it's scary I
mean it is is not a small decision to
make but I also think here's one
potential upside if you tell the truth
and stand on principle and you know act
in a dignified way as a man the people
around you want that women want that
they don't want to be married to a wuss
and I I do think you know in the dynamic
in marriage especially with small
children in the home is you know don't
screw it up we've got you know a lot at
stake we you know we need the money and
all that but I think if you say calmly
like you know I my dignity requires me
to tell the truth you will get a lot of
understanding and I think longterm your
wife will respect you more they want a
little fire in a man and your children
will respect you more and that is man
that is worth a lot I
think absolutely that's a very good
point well on also the example that
you're setting for your children right
cuz they're going to grow up and they're
going to be faced with similar dilemmas
yeah no one remembers the names the
people who killed Jonah Arc honestly to
to Pand her to your Catholic sensibility
but no for no I mean you know she kind
of you wouldn't want to be burned to
death that's the kind of last thing
you'd want on the other hand how'd you
like to be you know Immortal for your
bravery mhm I don't know they're there
they're actually much worse things than
that and and living like a slave is one
of them a lot of a lot of us here faced
a lot of uh adversity some more than
others uh maybe it would be important to
say what made you guys just say you
I'm not going on with this I'm
not acquiescing I'm not complying I'm
not going to do what I'm told I'm going
to be a free human being that speaks
truth to power what made you what was
that decision in you what was that spark
in you guys James I think you have a lot
of these instances yourself what was it
the spark that gets you to start or that
keeps you going or or what start I was
in college and my professors were
telling me how great communism was and
and I I went to Ruckers and there was a
statue of Paul Robison who was a
stalinist he won the Stalin Peace Prize
and Milton Freeman graduated from my
college and there was no statue of him
and I just said that doesn't make any
sense I wasn't even very political I
just thought that's I wasn't even I mean
you don't have to be a student of
History to you know but it's but it's
difficult and and uh I think that
there's been some trying moments in the
in the FBI uh you know you know I've
talked about that FBI raid that was that
was terrifying and I consider myself a a
a relatively Fearless person I'm I'm
afraid but not to the extent most people
are and and uh and it really made me
question the principles of the you know
it made me question everything I
believed in and and sometimes it's
discouraging but you got to grind it out
you got to keep keep fighting you got to
keep exposing and I'm very encouraged
right now by this by this uh these
whistleblowers coming forward I'm very
I'm very encouraged right now very
heartened Charlie my faith yeah if if
you uh if you love God and you believe
believe that he's Sovereign a lot of
this stuff doesn't matter especially if
Media Matters writes a nasty article
about you it doesn't matter not no one
cares there's an eternal game at Play
here and honestly I hate lying and I
hate bullies even more I I can't stand
when people use their power to go after
people that can't defend themselves that
sets me off and we're we're supposed to
tolerate those bullies and say that
they're they're good people no they're
they're evil and in fact if you love God
you must hate evil it's my mission
statement verse Psalm 9710 those of you
love God must hate
evil how would you describe the spark
Tucker um well I agree with Charlie that
if you know if you don't view death as
the worst thing and I don't by the way
it's inevitable anyway but I don't I
don't view it as the end and I don't
view it as the worst thing that could
happen to a person that resets your
framework for sure but in my my case if
I'm being honest it's really the family
that I grew up and I grew up in a you
know
non-traditional very unusual family um
but a totally Eon clastic family
completely it was like not even a
question are we going along with
everyone else what no and in an
extremely close family very very close
family it was only three of us but very
close and um and then I grew to have at
a very young I got married at 22 and I
had my own family like that and I've had
the same friends for 40 years almost all
of them and so the world that I actually
occupy is a world that rewards those
things and I felt so supported by it and
I always have my whole life I've never
been alone I've lived I went to boarding
school at 14 I've lived alone for one
year of my life and I've you know always
kind of shared a bathroom with somebody
and uh and so I just have a lot of
really close relationships and
supportive relationships and so like if
they hate me at some I've been fired a
number of times and obviously half the
world hates me it kind of doesn't matter
when I go home because the people in my
world are honest and kind and supportive
and like I I really feel for people who
live by themselves and who don't have
that because how could you be brave
under those
circumstances you just I I couldn't I'm
not man enough to be brave and go home
to an empty apartment I can't even
imagine that and I and I really
disapprove of a society that creates
that life for people particularly young
people you've got no backup at all so I
feel for people a lot I'm lucky you know
I don't I don't know if there was a
grand formative little little moments
throughout my life that made me question
reality and things like that but I'm
lucky that I had a good mom and a good
dad
and uh dad was a little more
conservative mom was a little more
little more liberal so I got you know
I'm in in between view on a lot of
things and logic behind it but more
importantly I was I was always taught
that uh uh to challenge to question that
not everybody is always right I wonder I
think a lot of it may come from the fact
that my dad is a firefighter and one of
the one of the most important things you
learn is when you enter a building where
your exits and you have to understand
that sometimes when there's an emergency
everyone will run in the wrong direction
are you stopping to think about which
door you're going through you know I
remember seeing this video of a music
venue a fire starts everybody
immediately runs through the front door
and they gets stuck and a guy calmly
walks out the side door with no
resistance films the whole thing that's
how I grew up I I grew up with parents
telling me to be careful to watch my
step and to think ahead I just I suppose
I have a good family Sheamus um I was
also blessed with an Incredible family
and my parents were very uh active
pro-life activist through the 70s 80s
and '90s and 2000s and when I was a kid
they would bring us to pro-life events
and that was actually my gateway to
getting involved in politics I just
thought this is the single most
important possible issue people are
they're they're murdering unborn babies
and I remember the way the pro-life
cause was always sneered at by teachers
in school or messaging that I saw on the
mainstream Media or people I knew who
were on the political left but I knew so
many people whose lives my parents had
literally saved because in spite of what
the left will tell you pro-life
activists many of them do care and when
they persuade a woman to choose life
they will stay in her life and there
were people like that in my life growing
up and I got to a certain age and I
realized like this friend of mine or
this person I love is here they are
alive because my parents were brave
enough to say we love you don't do this
that's a person we don't want this life
for you and we care about your child and
no matter how annoying or chromogen or
out of place I was told it was to say
don't kill an unborn child I thought I
would rather be The Annoying out ofpl
person who saves lives than the person
who never commits a social faux paw and
allow his unborn children to die Y and I
don't mean to compare myself to my
parents I have not done nearly any
anything close to the good work that
they've done interacting with the real
people in the real world in and the the
children they've saved in the
responsibility they've taken for
children uh who weren't Theirs to help
them and so for me it was just a
recognition that the people who are
telling you not to speak up when you
have to are the people who are on the
side of death I I'll try to keep my
answer as short as possible but uh I
grew up in New York City on 9/11 and
there was a lot of death a lot of people
who lost loved ones a lot of people who
are losing their lives because the
government told them that the air was
safe to breathe I was around a lot of
that death I saw a lot of the people
that I loved that I cared for die uh in
front of me and a lot of them when they
were dying always had this message that
they they wish that they live their life
to the fullest a lot of them had regret
that their life was cut early that their
loved ones life was cut early and ever
since then that has reinvigorated a fire
in me personally that every time I
confronted a politician whether it was
BF brazinski that helped finance the
muajin and the al- Qaeda that
essentially became them when I
confronted you know David Rockefeller
and and and Lord Jacob rild when I was
looking in their eyes I was looking at
them knowing that these people are
capable of the ultimate Evil they're
capable of pulling something off like
9/11 so I had conviction knowing that
these people were the absolute deepest
darkest Sinister evil that you could
ever imagine looking them in the eyes
telling them off videotaping it made the
biggest difference inspired a lot of
individuals and showed everyone that we
had the power to address these issues to
speak truth expose these larger lives in
our society and live a life that is
worth living fighting these evil
scumbags we've got only a few minutes
left so I want to do some go around for
final thoughts and uh shout outs if
there's anything you want to shout out
but uh Luke just we'll start with you
and then of course we'll we need to get
Ian back out here in a moment so he can
also join us yeah if you want to support
me go to the bestp political show.com um
I'm doing my own show and I have a lot
of fun we shoot in Miami uh if you want
to get the shirt you get it on the best
political shirts.com I appreciate all
the support I appreciate the
opportunities really means a lot just to
be able to share with you guys and and
be able to to share the stage and and
have these conversations which I think
are really important so thank you
Charlie and thank you everyone final
thought real quick on the State of
Affairs and where we're
going we're
only if we believe it right right
on James wow final thoughts and anything
to shout out um well first of all thank
you Charlie for for having my back he's
a good man and as I was going through
this crazy crazy thing fired from the
company I founded which is UN
Unthinkable unimaginable occurrence
Charlie was there for me every day so I
just want to say am James you're my
brother and I appreciate the morning
prayers thank you um as far as shoutouts
I'm speaking on stage tomorrow at 10:00
a.m. I've got some new whistleblowers
coming on stage some very brave people
and then at 2 p p.m. tomorrow we're
doing an investigative journalism
Workshop undercover work is not for
everyone but if you're interested
tomorrow at 2 p.m. final thoughts I'm an
Optimist I I I have to be I I I have to
have faith although there are moments
when I I I agree with you but I I wake
up the next day and I think this is what
a time to be alive I mean there's no
other place in history I'd rather be
than right here right now because we can
make a difference and I'm excited to
make a difference and we will make a
difference next year so that's my final
thought well first I'm just what a great
America Fest right everybody this has
just been amazing this just been awesome
so and I want to I want to give a couple
shout outs uh to our Tech team that got
this together in 15 minutes is that not
amazing they put this and assembled it
it's absolutely incredible uh the staff
has been has been great um and if anyone
wants to join Turning Point USA we'd
love to have you be part of our movement
uh it's growing like crazy uh YouTube is
playing games with the Charlie Kirk
Channel right now we received a strike
for something we shouldn't have um so if
you guys are watching on YouTube if you
can go subscribe to our YouTube channel
helps a lot you know what it's like to
get a strike it suppresses your reach by
90% for 90 days the way to break out of
that is if a bunch of people go
subscribe and like videos so if anyone's
watching online and wants to help us out
um I think it's real Charlie Kirk you
guys could help us there um and really
help us get out of this ridiculous
strike where I said something that I
won't say now because I don't want you
to get a strike um and you also could
take out your phone and subscribe to the
Charlie Kirk Show podcast we would
deeply appreciate it we need you on
Rumble we we are on Rumble um but I'm
with Tim on this if you want to reach
the middle you have to go on YouTube
right we're we're on Rumble too but we
just have the live we we were averaging
8 million uh YouTube shorts uh views a
day and then obviously you know what
happens um huge hu and then all Media
Matters everyone try to take us out so
we got a strike and so the way we get
around that is if a bunch of people go
to the channel subscribe and like some
videos it could Spike our stuff up um
and uh once we get over the strike God
it's also so North Korean it's just
absolutely crazy um first let me just
say I'm I'm really excy to meet you I've
wanted to me too thanks oh thank you um
and thank you for having me this has
been wild and you're kind of bringing me
a little bit
closer no I just I love that you know
anybody it's the Holy Spirit not me no
it's just anybody who devotes his or her
life to helping other people in the most
unfashionable possible way bringing unto
themselves responsibilities they don't
need like that's the highest form of
sincerity so that's really that's a very
winning that's winning to me like I I
love that um we just started this new
network it's a tuckercarlson.com we
think it's going to make a difference
and uh we we also think it's uncan since
it's a subscription model so anyway
thank you for having me absolutely I
really do appreciate it of course you
can uh follow me at timcast you can
follow the show at timcast IRL just
wanted to say uh Tucker when you were
still on Fox every day after the show
Luke would run downstairs because he
tooed your show why you got to do this
to me man because it's respect it's
respect always would make sure to watch
so I really do appreciate you being here
it's an honor and a privilege and uh
want to shout out chamus but can we also
make sure we get Ian back on for the for
closing statements as well yeah well for
God bless you and thank you for for
those kind words sincerely uh thank you
um one thing I'll say is to first to
promote my stuff and then give my
feelings on the current state of affairs
uh I'm a cartoonist I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we make
animated comedy and satire uh thank you
thank you and this Thursday we're
releasing a Christmas special okay it's
the most ambitious video we've ever made
it's 8 minutes of full animation and
it's like the most insane and hilarious
thing that we've ever written and come
up with so please go to freedom jins and
subscribe I think you guys will really
enjoy it um and what I want my closing
statement to be oh hey baby finish it up
so what I want my closing statement to
be is this
um we'll give it a second it's making it
hard for Sheamus don't hit a camera
that's that's my closing statement No
don't fall off the stage at like you did
last time so what I want to say is that
um when you tell a lie could use when
you tell a lie when you say something
that isn't true you don't feel like
you've gotten a fact wrong you feel like
you've betrayed somebody and the reason
for that is because the truth is not an
abstraction the truth is a person and
that person is Jesus Christ and he loves
you he loves you and he died for you and
he wants you in his church so God bless
all of you I love you and I am praying
for every single one of you special
thanks special thanks to all these guys
up on stage you guys are incredible
Charlie thank you so much for putting
this on man every year it gets better
and better dude I love you so much thank
you so much you're the man everyone else
remember Jesus was a
this conversation is not ending tonight
let's make magic all of us
together brother see you later everybody
thank you all so much subscribe like
share you can uh check out our new song
at the bestsong ever.com and we will see
you all
[Applause]
tomorrow